(gentle music plays)
Old growth redwoods
that tower 200, 300 feet above the ground,
their root structures only run six to 12 feet deep.
So what holds a redwood up through really rough weather
is not it's trunk that you see,
it's this deep stuff that's underground,
but it's only as deep as it is lateral
because it's held together by a community of other trees.
When the weather is really rough,
what kind of foundation do you have
holding you to the ground?
And these are often qualities that people don't see.
Ambition is a good thing: it's laudable.
But hustle culture, on the other hand,
I think we can all agree
extracts a cost, a cost in the form of exhaustion,
frayed relationships, even substance abuse,
being just a few of the many undesirable side effects of,
of what I would call
an obsessive relationship with performance.
True success, on the other hand, requires sustainability,
a healthier model for striving, rooted not in compulsion,
but coming from a place of wholeness and love.
Well, here today to elaborate is Brad Stulberg,
a writer and coach
specializing in human performance and wellbeing.
Brad is the author of three books,
including his most recent, "The Practice of Groundedness."
His writing has appeared everywhere
from the New York Times and Wire
to the New Yorker, GQ, and Time.
He is a Fellow
at the University of Michigan's
Graduate School of Public Health,
and he is the co-founder of, "The Growth Equation,"
newsletter and podcast,
alongside elite track and field coach, Steve Magnus.
Quick note, before we get into it,
a bit of a trigger warning,
we do discuss a few intense mental health topics,
including suicidal ideation in fairly graphic detail,
so sensitive viewers, please be advised.
That aside, amidst the chaos and the confusion
that is the self-help world,
I find Brad to be a fairly principled
and welcome voice of reason as well as a like-minded soul.
And this conversation just brims over
with evidence and experience-based counsel
on how to craft successful life with staying power.
So without further ado, please hit that subscribe button,
thank you, and enjoy.
Good to see you, my friend. It's been a couple years.
This is podcast number three,
but your first solo appearance on the show.
I'm excited to unpack your latest book
and all these wisdom tools
that you're so good at sharing with people.
And every time I think about you or I see you,
I remember vividly the first time that we talked.
It was for an article
that I think you were writing for Outside.
You called me,
and I remember exactly where I was.
I was sitting in my truck in this parking lot,
outside this other office that I had, and we ended up,
I thought we were gonna talk for like 10 minutes
and we ended up talking for like an hour.
And I remember getting off that call and just thinking,
"This guy is like on my wavelength."
Like we just immediately synced up on these I ideas
that have gone on to become
the foundation of these books that you write.
And this shared sensibility that I think we have
where we kind of have this bristled resistance
to the flavor of the month self-help, you know,
that we see kind of shared on social media, et cetera,
a shared allergy to the life hack culture
and relentless optimization
and all this kind of reductive, binary,
conclusions and statements about the pursuit of excellence.
So it's good to kind of further that discussion
and it's nice to be, you know, that that conversation,
you know, ended up with a friendship
and what we're about to do here today.
So welcome.
It's great to be here.
So the latest book is called,
"The Practice of Groundedness."
So why don't you talk a little bit about
what inspired you to write this book?
Because I think the kind of origin story
of what you were enduring and going through that,
that prompted you to dive into this subject matter
is super interesting.
Yeah.
So the shortly after
my first book came out,
that I co-authored with Steve Magnus, "Peak Performance,"
I was doing some media for the book in New York City
and went on a long run in Central Park;
I don't know, 18, 20 miles,
as long as I could go back then.
And was super busy throughout the rest of the day.
So had an interview here, a podcast there,
and just lived on a Cliff Bar.
And I was under the impression
that I was meeting a close friend,
a guy named Adam Altar for dinner,
and turns out it was just a bar.
So I had two stiff drinks and some Kettle Chips,
and my blood sugar plummeted.
And unbeknownst to me then,
something that happens when your blood sugar plummets
is you can become super jittery and anxious.
And I had a massive panic attack.
I had never experienced anything like it.
I felt like I was gonna die.
My heart was pounding out of my neck,
just totally out of control.
And I got through the night, it was rough.
At the time my younger brother
was finishing up medical school,
so I'm on the phone with him for like two hours.
And I think he knows immediately, I'm having a panic attack.
So fine, "You're fine,"
but when you're in the middle of that
and you don't believe it.
And the next day I went to an Urgent Care clinic
to get myself checked out
before getting out of flight to go home
and they took my blood sugar.
It was fine then
and the doc there said,
"Yeah, it sounds like your blood sugar got super low.
You had a panic attack."
And when most people have a panic attack,
it's a one-and-done kind of thing.
It's an awful experience; they move on from it.
For me, it really latched on to my psyche,
and I just developed this like omnipresent,
bad anxiety, related to everything health.
And I got in to see a therapist.
I got in to see my doctor.
They're running all these tests for heart rate-this,
liver-that, adrenal gland-that
ruling out all the health stuff,
and everything's coming back fine,
but I still don't feel fine.
So for about three weeks
I lived in this place of just terrible health anxiety.
And maybe a month into it, I started feeling a lot better.
And I had seen a therapist a few times.
I was no longer looking for like an organic cause;
just anxiety.
I accepted it.
And I was feeling good enough to go on a long car ride
to meet some close friends for a running and camping trip.
And about an hour and a half into this four hour car ride,
I just got absolutely pummeled by the thought
that you could just drive off the road and end it.
And it came completely outta left field.
Is that the first instance in your life
of having any kind of suicidal ideation?
Yes.
Yeah.
Scary.
Terrifying.
And not just the thought,
but the accompaniment of that thought
with just a head-to-toe wave
of just dread and anxiety, you know,
stomach coming up into your throat.
And I couldn't stop thinking about it
for the rest of the drive.
I don't know how I made it there.
It was just an utterly torturous drive.
And I got there, and then throughout the entire weekend,
I was just constantly bombarded
by these thoughts of self-harm.
So I'd wake up in the middle of a night to pee
and my brain would be like,
"You could go down in the kitchen
and stab yourself with a knife."
And it was just freaking unrelenting.
And I didn't let anyone there know what I was going through
because these weren't like my closest friends
and this was all so very bizarre to me.
And I made it-
Did you call your wife
or your therapist or anything like that?
Yeah.
I mean, my wife kind of knew,
but I also didn't wanna scare her, you know?
So I was really holding on to most of this myself
and it was the weekend.
I didn't have my therapist's phone number,
cause as far as she knew,
I was just like a run of the mill case of like some,
some simple to moderate health anxiety.
Made it through the weekend
and was just completely like
white knuckling myself getting ready for the drive home,
just hoping that it wouldn't happen again,
which the wrong thing to do I learned later,
and of course the whole drive home,
it's like 10 times as bad as the way there:
by far, the worst four hours of my life,
just terrible.
Got home, told my wife that something's going on.
I'm sick. Something is wrong with my brain.
I need help.
I learned that while it's very hard
to get into a psychiatrist if you just have anxiety,
if you have any kind of suicidal ideation
you can get seen immediately the next day.
Yeah.
Right.
So I was, I was seen the next day
and my doctor, Dr. Lucas Van Dyke,
I'll never forget.
I was just terrified and traumatized
and I'm telling him this story
and that I thought I was actually gonna do it,
and just how awful it felt,
and I remember asking him,
saying like, you know, "I need to go
to be in an inpatient facility somewhere,
like sign me up for that, cause I don't wanna hurt myself.
I just wanna know I'm safe."
And he's sitting across from me like this
and he just kind of chuckles,
it's kinda laughing for, and he's like,
"You're not depressed. You're not suicidal.
You just have OCD."
That's such a strange counterintuitive diagnosis.
And at that moment,
my whole just affect, my shoulders dropped,
it was like, I was free, because I was scared.
I thought that I really was
like going to act on those thoughts.
And over the next year I learned what OCD is
and how it can manifest in different ways.
And one of those manifestations is
having intrusive thoughts about self-harm.
So it was actually not like a bizarre case of OCD.
It's a pretty common theme.
What triggers that?
What is the prompt for suddenly, out of the blue,
being obsessed with a recurring looping thought
of self-harm?
You know, there's no one answer to that question.
Clearly the anxiety
that I was experiencing after the panic attack
was like priming my brain,
my nervous system, to be on heightened alert.
But why it went in that direction
and why it happened at that moment, it's hard to say.
There's some speculation in the research community
that OCD intrusive thoughts
tend to latch onto the things that people care most about.
So people that are really worried about
or care deeply about like perfectionism,
they tend to have OCD around germs and germ phobia,
because like a germ is gross; it's not perfect.
And I love life. I'm like an optimistic, positive guy.
My wife was pregnant with our first kid at the time.
It's like OCD found like the perfect dagger.
And it's just like,
"Let's go stab this guy with it
over and over and over again."
Yeah. It's really strange.
I've never heard it characterized in,
in the manner in which you've suffered.
Like I've had periods in my life
where I've been the guy
who's like organizing his pencils and,
and having strange rituals
that I've convinced myself are important
and related to some goal that I'm seeking
and if I skip them, then I'm jeopardizing the whole thing.
Like I don't know what causes that and it's pretty mild,
but I have seen myself do that kind of thing.
And I think that's what
people's common-
Yes.
kind of understanding of what OCD is.
But this seems, you know, obviously,
not only qualitatively different,
but also more severe.
Yeah.
And, and I think what you're describing there
is the visible compulsion.
So you might have some thought, which is like, "Hey,
if I don't organize my pencils, my book's gonna flop,"
or, "My wife's gonna leave me."
And then you organize the pencils.
Whereas the actual issue is not the organizing the pencils.
It's the thought and then you try to make it go away.
So the level of severity
is often related to the thought and the anxiety it causes.
So some people,
they do have an organizational compulsion
around what's called harm OCD.
So they might have a thought that,
"Hey, I'm gonna kill myself," or other harm,
"I'm gonna push someone into traffic."
And in order to make that thought go away,
they go touch a door knob 10 times.
My compulsions weren't visible. They were all psychological.
So my compulsion was
trying to figure out what was going on
and reassure myself that I wouldn't do it.
So I would spend hours Googling signs of suicide,
and signs of depression, and the pathways of that
trying to convince myself that it wasn't gonna happen to me,
which of course just makes the OCD worse,
because OCD is like a what-if machine.
You're just deepening that groove.
Yeah. It's a, what if machine.
"Well, what if that doesn't?
What if I'm different?"
Or, "What if I do go down this pathway?"
But yeah, why it latched onto that?
The best guess that I have,
the best guess that my therapist had
is just that I love life
and OCD goes right after the things that you love the most.
Hmm.
So you got some relief from the diagnosis,
but obviously that's not the solution to the problem.
How did you heal from this?
Right!
Because the what-if machine, like two days later is like,
"Well what if the psychiatrist is wrong?"
(general soft laughter)
I mean, that was the thought that I had for a month.
Like, "Oh, he's misdiagnosing me."
The first thing I wanted to do is get a second opinion
because I was just scared I was gonna harm myself.
And the psychiatrist is like, you know,
"You can if you want,
but that's only gonna set you back
because the therapy for OCD
is something that's called exposure and response prevention.
So you expose yourself
to the thing that causes the distress,
and then you prevent
the response that makes that distress go away.
So walk me through what that looked like in your case.
Sure.
So for me, the exposures were reading deeply
about people suffering from terrible depression,
watching videos
of people jumping off the Golden Gate Bridge,
just gruesome stuff that would bring up
these feelings of that could happen to me.
I could do this to myself,
and then not going to Google
or try to call my therapist
or convince myself that it wasn't gonna be me.
And if anything,
when you have the thought that it could be you
in therapy,
you're just supposed to agree with that thought.
You say, "Yeah, it might be,
but I'm gonna get back to what's in front of me right now."
That's pretty intense, to watch that.
I mean, that feels like aversion therapy to me, like,
Well it is, in a way.
For an alcoholic to go, "All right,
you need to go drink as much as possible
and get sick so that you don't do it again.
They've realized that-
But it's,
that as ineffective.
But it's not about getting sick.
It's about desensitizing yourself to the fact
that you can watch something like that.
and you can have those feelings
without deeply knowing that you're going to do that.
Disassociating it or depersonalizing it.
Yes.
And knowing that, to be clear, like I was so fortunate,
the psychiatrist I saw,
it just so happened that his whole research program
was on OCD.
I didn't know this.
Wow.
Then the therapist-
But then the, the, inside you're like,
"Yeah, but he's a hammer looking for a nail."
Well, of course I had all those thoughts,
but over the course of my treatment,
I was very lucky because this kind of OCD
is very commonly misdiagnosed as major depression.
And then people are institutionalized
for like suicidal ideation, which technically
at the time I thought that's what this was,
but this is called just like intrusive thinking,
and it's that theme.
So I'm very fortunate
that I got on this treatment pathway so quickly.
And ultimately, and I'll share that here
and I think it's important to,
to say that, I don't know what the right word is.
If it's a trigger warning, or if, if you're suffering,
obviously, you don't take my advice, Rich's advice,
you go talk to a professional.
But the ultimate thing that got me through this,
and this is gonna sound crazy,
is it was shortly after Thanksgiving
and I a pretty rough holiday.
I just wasn't feeling good.
I was still having all these intrusive thoughts
and the way that exposure and response prevention,
this therapy works,
is you start with things that aren't as intense,
and then you gradually work your way up
to very intense things.
And I had been watching those videos
and listening to podcasts about, you know,
people that have suffered with suicidal ideation
and the like,
and my therapist could tell I was pretty dejected.
And we'd been doing this for about three months.
And I just said like, "Brooke, I, this,
I don't feel like I'm getting that much better."
She's like, "Well, like if you wanna get better,
it's gonna be really hard."
And I'm like, "That's fine."
And she probably talked to my psychiatrist to do this.
And again, she also has a specialty in OCD
and she said,
"Here's what I want you to do.
For the next 10 days, when Caitlin," my partner,
"is not home,
I want you to take a knife
and hold it to your neck on the couch."
Whoa!
Yeah.
And I was just, it'd been four months,
I had written this book, I'm an athlete,
like I freaking love life and all that was sucked outta me.
So I was desperate. At that point I'm like, "You know what,
if I do it, I do it."
And Brooke's like, "And I'll take responsibility.
If you do it, it's on me."
And something about her saying that, said like,
"Screw it. I'm gonna do it."
And then she's like, "If you have an urge to push it,
you might, like follow that urge.
See what happens."
Yeah.
Holy.
Right.
So I'm sitting there on the couch and the first day,
of course, I'm panicking and I have an urge.
and I'm like,
And I really wanna call Brooke,
but I don't because she's like, "You can't call me."
And I just wanna, like, I wanna, deep down inside
I clearly wanna get better.
That's why I'm doing this and it's terrifying.
So I push it a little bit more and then I stop.
And then that night I completely freak out.
I'm like, "I had the urge.
Like tomorrow I'm gonna do it.
Because I didn't do it today,
I got lucky, something stopped me,
but tomorrow I'm gonna do it."
So it's this tension of not wanting
to do the exercise again,
but knowing that that's what's gonna get me through
and just having the ultimate trust in Brooke, my therapist.
So day two, feel the urge,
follow it a little bit more, don't do it.
Panic attack that night.
Day three, kind of feel the urge, but don't really care.
I kid you not Rich, by day nine,
I fell asleep on the couch from boredom,
cause I had to sit there for an hour.
And that was part of it.
She's like, "If you get bored, you just sit there."
Oh.
So the assignment was, you had to do it for a full hour?
For a full hour.
And the first couple days, like I said,
the whole time was just panicked,
by the ninth day, I swear I fell asleep.
I sat the knife down and I fell asleep cause I was so bored.
And that was the turning point for me.
And where's your partner in all of this?
So she knows.
And she's met with me and the therapist
and she's been educated
on what OCD is and how it manifests.
And she knew that you were engaging in this practice?
Yeah. I mean she knew it's a part of therapy.
And that had to be terrifying for her
knowing that you're in the other room?
Yes.
And again, like if, if people listening,
if you're like, "This guy's nuts, it's just crazy,"
you're right.
Google around OCD.
and like, this is actually very,
like this is just standard.
There's nothing crazy about this. This is standard protocol.
I'll give you a couple of other examples
cause OCD has these like very bizarre pathways.
So one pathway is people think that, as I mentioned,
they're gonna harm other people
so they don't leave their house.
Especially like you live in a big city,
you're scared to go on the subway
cause you think you're gonna push someone in front of it.
So what do those people do?
They spend two hours a day on the platform of the subway
going as close to people as they can.
And then they gradually do it.
So once the diagnosis is made
and a professional is sure that that's the diagnosis,
the therapies, while they seem extreme, are like textbook.
And the other thing that's very hopeful
if people are listening and might be suffering from OCD
or know someone that is,
is that through exposure and response prevention therapy,
outcomes are phenomenal.
Like 80% of people get better.
On top of this, there's a very interesting,
complicated, and I presume disorienting,
I knew you were
gonna go there (laughs)
layer, you know,
as you're this guy who's published these books
and, you know, has, you know,
published articles in all these big magazines,
really on the subject of like how to live better, right?
Yeah.
How to be, you know, your most actualized self,
how to achieve your fitness goals and your lifestyle goals.
If it was me, I would be experiencing
profound shame and confusion
while all of this is going on like,
I was
I'm supposed to be the guy
who's helping other people figure out these problems,
not the person who's suffering,
not just suffering, but like profoundly suffering.
Yeah, I was for sure.
And I wasn't writing during that time period,
I was just focused on like getting through every day.
And I remember a turning point on that theme
was gradually as the OCD started to get a little bit better,
just a little, like I had a foothold.
I was in Virginia with my brother
and we were supposed to be having
just a fun weekend together,
much fun as you can have
when you're four months my into this,
and I got an email, from this young fellow
who's I think like 25 or 26.
In the email, and he's basically like,
"Hey, I wanna follow your path.
You're this young person, you have it all together,
you've written these books, how do you do it?"
And meanwhile, I was, that day,
like scared to be in the kitchen
of the place we were renting
because there were knives in it.
And the amount of cognitive dissonance
and distress that that caused,
even though I hadn't been putting out much work,
just that people in the world saw me as that,
and here I was completely falling apart,
that, in that moment, was worse than the OCD itself.
As you said, just holding that shame
and just this feeling of like living these two lives.
Right. The duplicitous nature of all of it.
Yeah.
And so that I presume is what catalyzed you
to kind of come clean and write that article
that you wrote that got shared widely?
Yeah.
And I don't, you know,
I wouldn't necessarily say come clean
because to me it wasn't about like, I wasn't gonna,
You weren't hiding it,
but just-
and I wasn't
weren't yourself.
gonna keep writing. Bingo.
It was less about coming clean;
it was more about just continuing to be a writer
because I remember telling Brooke, my therapist,
that, "I'm done writing.
Like I can't write about this stuff
when I'm going through this."
She's like, "That's a cop out."
She's like,
"You gotta play through the pain."
and we decided that for me to continue as a writer,
I wasn't gonna do it with this huge cognitive dissonance.
So yeah, I wrote the story
and then writing the story itself,
this is one more insight and I know we'll move on from this
but just to like give you a sense of the weird OCD brain,
the part of writing that story that was terrifying
wasn't like, "Oh, what are people gonna think of me?"
You know, there was maybe a little bit of that,
but by then, it's like, "Screw it.
I don't care.
I'm just like happy to be doing a little bit better."
But I was so scared that by writing a story
about what I was going through,
it would be as if I was asserting myself over OCD,
like, "I have some control of this.
I have enough control about this to write about it."
And then it would come back with a vengeance.
So that was my fear in writing the thing.
And, again, like back to this fault.
Like go through your anxiety,
it's like,
"No, like the thing that I have to do is write it,
go through, and then, yeah,
I had no idea this was gonna happen.
But then the piece got shared everywhere.
I get literally thousands of emails from people saying,
"Oh, me too, or my brother or not OCD,
but depression, or bipolar, or you name it."
And some of these emails were coming from people
that I would've never guessed are,
are suffering in any way.
And that was really a pivot point
on my journey as a writer,
from exploring topics that are,
I'd say like peak topics.
So when everything's clicking and things are going well
to thinking more about,
"Well, what about when things aren't going well?"
Or, "How do you build a solid enough foundation
to be able to weather these various storms?"
And also from writing about these peak experiences
from a rather clinical perspective,
to this lived experience version
of what it means to grapple with these ideas.
Yes.
And I would suspect that writing that article, you know,
is an act of self-love
that left you feeling more integrated.
And of course, with the response,
feeling more connected to other people,
like it is part of the healing process for this.
So although your OCD mind is telling you
that this might catalyze a snap back,
it actually was part of the process of becoming whole again.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
It's the best thing that I could have done.
And then, you know, people reach out to me that,
"Oh, hey, will you coach me because
I'm a partner-
you understand,
at this firm, but I also have OCD,"
or, "I'm an entrepreneur,
but I suffer from depression."
And, sure enough, like most people
have something, throw addiction in there,
it's like 70% of the population.
Yeah. Yeah.
So with this epiphany
and this pain body that you had,
this kind of leads you down this rabbit hole
of trying to understand, not only what caused this,
but, you know, the kind of more macro, grand,
you know, grand idea of like,
what is leading people, you know,
people with good intentions
who are ambitious and goal oriented,
like what is kind of leading them away
from the path that they seek?
I mean, how do you think about, you know,
what led you into the subject matter terrain of the book?
Yeah.
So I have come out of that experience
and I, and the book didn't start until,
I don't know, a year after my diagnosis.
So I was out of the woods of deep OCD.
I'd say I was in those woods for about eight, nine months.
And by month 10,
I was seeing my therapist maybe once every three weeks,
once every four weeks.
So I was doing much better.
I was back to functioning
and perhaps even high functioning
at that point in my life.
And a lot of what I had been reading at the time
wasn't necessarily about OCD, but this is pre-pandemic.
Lots of people just feeling like.
"I'm striving for this success,"
or, "I'm trying to be excellent and great,
but I feel like crap.
I feel anxious. I feel depressed.
I can never feel content." You name it.
And coming out of a year of therapy,
well these topics had been on my mind
in the most extreme way
so that is ultimately what crystallized in this idea of,
"Hey, what if I try to write a book
that takes conventional ways
of thinking about success and excellence
and kind of flips 'em on their head
and tries to both redefine
those types of things that we strive for
and also the path to get them."
So that's going on in my brain on the one hand,
on the other hand, I'm hearing from coaching clients,
from readers of my work, that they're all struggling
with various discontents in their own life.
And then the third thing is, coming out of therapy
I got super into reading like, Buddhism, Taoism,
all these Eastern religions,
and some stoicism too on the West,
and all these ancient teachers
are basically saying the exact same thing
that is now considered evidence-based therapy.
And it was like those three things came together
and said in my brain,
"Oh, there might be a book here,
or at the very least
this is something I'm deeply curious about,
so I wanna explore it."
Right.
It's sort of choose your adventure: Taoism, Buddhism,
Christianity, Stoicism, I'd throw AA in there as well
because a lot of these tools that you're talking about
are really fundamental to recovery,
and the parlance of like how you get better.
And it's interesting how those parallels
just kind of recur and show up
across these various philosophies and,
and you know, ways of living.
I think about it as a three-legged stool.
And I stole this, I think-
We talked about
that last time.
Yeah I stole this from my collaborator, Steve.
The first leg is modern science and empirical studies.
So what is happening
in rigorous, methodology sound, experiments that is true.
The second leg is ancient wisdom in history.
So what have people been talking about for millennia
and what patterns and themes are there?
And then the third leg is daily practice.
So when I go out and coach people,
or when I put on my reporting hat and ask people,
"Well, Hey, what kind of tools you use?
What works and what doesn't?" that's daily practice.
And in this book, for anything to make it in there,
it had to be able to stand on all three of those legs,
because I'm interested in
what I call truth with a capital T:
so principles, concepts, skills,
that are gonna work for most people in most circumstances.
(music plays softly)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated
by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share:
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book,
"Voicing Change, Volume Two."
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation
of the magic, inspiration, and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change,"
was a beautifully rendered book
worthy of display on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume, or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you
to revisit the wisdom of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained within.
"Voicing Change, Volume Two," available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today, only @richroll.com.
Right.
Well, all of this tracks back to this idea that you have,
that you characterize as heroic individualism, right?
So explain what that is,
because I think that kind of creates the foundation
for everything we're gonna explore.
Love it.
So heroic individualism, I define as
a constant game of one up-manship
against both self and others
where measurable achievement is the main arbiter of success.
Right.
Which basically means, you know, everybody, you know,
Like this is,
Yeah. We are all,
on some level,
this is a societal problem.
Yeah. We are all, we are all like, I'm reading about this
and I'm like, "Yeah, that's me a hundred percent."
It's everyone-
that's me today.
we swim in this water.
Right.
And I think the other part of the definition
that's really important
is that regardless of what you tell yourself,
the finish line that is lasting fulfillment
is always 10 yards down the field.
So, if I just hit a hundred million downloads,
then I'll be content.
You hit it, you're content for a day.
If I just publish that book,
if I just get promoted to the C-suite,
if I just-then, thinking;
always fails.
Right.
It is literally the basis
of the four noble truths in Buddhism.
And it is now, in modern behavioral science,
called the arrival fallacy,
which is this notion
that we think we're gonna arrive somewhere
and that will make us happy;
that will make us feel a certain way.
And we just set ourselves up for suffering
because we get there,
maybe we get a short blip of happiness,
and then we adapt back to where we were.
On top of that, in addition
to the goal post always moving,
it's almost like those Chinese finger traps, like the,
the more ambitious you are, the more type A you are,
the more suffering you create for yourself,
like the more heightened that, that level of,
of angst and consternation is going to be for you.
Yes.
And particularly now, I wanna be really clear
both in this conversation
and then hopefully I was clear enough in the book
that this is a societal thing.
Like this is the water that we swim in.
Social media is a personality marketplace.
Like people trade shares of you and followers.
The proliferation of metrics in every field,
including like these old,
like what used to be an art field, medicine,
everything is now on a dashboard.
So we're constantly connecting ourselves
in what we're trying to strive for
to some kind of external arbiter of success
and that's a tough kind of pool to be swimming in.
Right.
Short of becoming a complete Luddite
or living some sort of Thoreau-like experience,
acknowledging that we live in the modern world
and that there are benefits to many of these things,
but what's broken is our relationship to them.
A hundred percent.
And that's it.
I mean, that's what groundedness is all about,
is it's, "How can you strive for excellence and success
in a way that the good outweighs the bad
and that you try to stop yourself
from walking into some of those traps?"
Because, I'll say this, you know right now, Rich,
very fashionable to have like this anti-ambition argument.
There's been a lot of articles
and a lot of books circulating
and I think it's like gobbledygook.
I don't buy it.
I'm really glad that people have ambition.
Like the person I always give
as the example is Katalin Karikó,
who's the Hungarian woman
that developed the mRNA technology.
And profiles of her;
she's like a workaholic for 20 years on this research.
I'm really glad that she was ambitious.
And I also find it kind of ironic
that a lot of the people that are writing
the anti-ambition books, are super ambitious,
about selling their anti-ambitious book.
(Rich laughs) You know-
So it's like a
little bit of like a Rorschach test?
like what you look at and what you see.
So I don't,
I think ambition, and progress, and striving,
is a good thing.
I think setting a goal and chasing it
there's a lot of life to be had there, as you said,
it's about our relationship with that.
Well, you know, a couple reflections on that.
I mean, yes, there is, you know,
I think there's a huge Reddit thread board, anti-work.
Anti-work.
Like there's a massive swath of the population
who is into this idea, but what's driving that?
What's driving that is a lack of purpose and fulfillment
that they're attracting from their work life, right?
So that's a more endemic problem.
If people felt purposeful, and directed and passionate
with all the paradox that's built into that of course,
perhaps that wouldn't be a thing, you know,
that's part of what's broken in our economy, I think,
and that's a different conversation,
but to the extent that you can and get plugged in
to something professional
that gives you sustenance on some level,
doesn't the conversation turn,
in terms of like how you're like thinking about this,
turn to the tension between
self-discipline on the one hand; yes,
we want the woman who's working on the mRNA vaccines
to work very hard on that for all of our benefit,
versus the self-compassion required to, you know,
be grounded and, you know, have a kind of broader sense of,
of what's important to better prioritize
our time, energy, focus, and attention.
Yes.
And I think that that is that's a gap
that hopefully this work helps to try to close a little
is, in this genre of books,
let's broadly call it
like personal development/personal growth,
there tends to be two big categories.
And I'm generalizing a little bit here, but I still think
there's truth in the generalization.
The first category is self discipline.
Wake up at 4:00 AM,
push, push, push,
go crush yourself.
Right.
Think like Gary V, just push.
And the second category-
Gary V, "Jocko" Willink-
Yeah.
David Goggins,
things like that.
And there's a lot of people that need that.
Oh, oh, I'm yeah.
I'm being totally non-judgemental.
I was, I'm gonna come back to that. So there's that.
And then there's like,
let's all hold hands, and sing "Kumbaya,"
and love each other,
and everything is self-love
and let's take care of ourselves.
And that's like the bookshelf
in most bookstores in this area.
And I think that true excellence requires
not either/or, but both/and.
So you need to take Goggins-
Not Gary oh,
And Jocko,
talk about nuance
And Gary V,
and gray areas-
and Tara Brock,
and you-
Sharon Salzberg
and you need to put them together.
Because you talk to anybody that's highly fulfilled,
that is living a good life, that is doing great things,
and that feels great about it,
and they are badass MF'ers,
but they're also so kind to themselves
and they're able to hold this paradox.
And if, if listeners take away anything from this,
it's like, it's not self-compassion or self discipline:
it's both/and,
and I actually argue that
it's self-compassion that allows you
to have such self-discipline cause it's freaking hard.
It's hard to wake up early. It's hard to push.
It's hard to fail.
So if you don't have the self-compassion there,
then you're never gonna last.
Right.
But if you're compassionate towards yourself
and you're also, you know,
very driven at the same time
when that alarm clock goes off at 4:30,
or whenever Jocko Willink's alarm clock goes off,
does the self-compassion say,
"Listen, you really need a good night's sleep
if you wanna function at your best,"
or does the self-compassion say,
"I care about what I'm doing
and I value, you know, who I am,
so I'm gonna get outta bed and, you know,
get out into the world and do my thing."
How do you know
the difference between-
The concrete answer is
I think it depends on the day.
Like if he's really tired and he needs to sleep,
but I mean that's wisdom-
which makes it
hard to drill down into like actionable, like,
this is my book, or my article,
or my listicle about how you do this.
Yeah. I mean it, yes.
And I think the definition of wisdom,
is like you learn from experience,
so you test those things and you see how it makes you feel.
I think that one way to,
to think about this is related to one's core values.
So this is a huge part about how I think about
what it means to be excellent or to be successful.
And core values are
these qualities that we hold as very aspirational.
So they are ourselves when we're at our best.
Things like love, creativity,
health, community, intellect:
just a few examples, right?
And for each core value that you have,
it's really good to define it in super concrete terms.
So you tell me a core value is love, or authenticity,
or vulnerability, well, what does that actually mean?
And then what are practices, day in and day out,
that you can show up to quote you, "mood follows action,"
regardless of how you're feeling and just act on.
And then that's how you live
in alignment with your core values.
So for Jocko, I don't know what his core values are,
but presumably there's something in there
that's gonna be around health on the one hand
and around waking up early
and crushing yourself on the other.
And life is just
a constant game of being very aware of those values,
perhaps a tension between them,
choosing accordingly, seeing how you feel,
and updating as you go.
Yeah, sure.
The idea of being value-based
is something James Clear talked about in, "Atomic Habits."
It's addressed in detail in your book, in the,
in sort of like, I don't know, two thirds,
three quarters of the way in,
you talk about this idea
of aligning your being with your actions,
because we can intellectualize, like,
"Oh, This is who I am, and this is what's important to me."
I understand that,
but how do you then translate that into action?
You have a couple people that you use as examples,
like coaching clients of yours,
like Parker and Samantha that you talk about.
Because I think that's the gap that most people relate to.
Like I think a lot of people, maybe they haven't
written down their values on a piece of paper,
but you know, it's up there,
if pressed they could probably tell you what they are,
but the struggle is
how do you translate that into something actionable
so that when you're moving forward in the world
and behaving in a certain way, there's an alignment there.
And when you are aligned, as you know,
like you feel more integrated as a human being,
when your actions are out of alignment with those values,
you feel that cognitive dissonance
and you don't feel quite yourself.
I think writing it down actually is really helpful.
Cause you mentioned like that's the first step of doing.
Cause being as, "Oh, I kind of know my, I values,
I have a sense of what they are."
My coaching clients come to me and they say that.
And then I ask them,
and we spend like six hours talking about it
because it's one thing to have a sense,
it's another thing to make it concrete and real.
And once you've gone through this process of making it real
well then it gets a lot easy.
so I'll, excuse me, a lot easier.
So I'll give you an example from my own life
of just like how concrete this gets, right?
So one of my core values is love.
Okay, a lot of people probably say,
"Yeah, love. Well, how on earth do you practice love?"
So I define it as being fully present
for the people and things that I care about.
Okay? So I have to define who are the people I care about?
What are the things I care about? Then I have that.
How do I be fully present for them?
Well, one way for example is at 6:15 PM every night,
my phone and computer go out in the garage
until my son is sleeping.
Okay, so I went from this
like very high level, esoteric, aspirational thing, love,
of all the way down to,
even if I really wanna get in that tweet
or check my email or whatever it is,
nope, my phone's gotta be in the garage.
And to me, unless you get that concrete,
it's very easy to fall into this trap of,
"Yeah, I'm values based. I know my values."
But are you actually, you actually living them?
So I think that there's some truth
to the saying, "What gets measured, gets managed."
So why don't we try to harness that
for the things that we actually care most about?
Right. Yeah.
I mean, that's great advice and good wisdom.
I think where it gets tricky is when
your values are in competition with each other,
because that's generally what happens.
Like perhaps another value you of yours is
to, you know, basically be this
creator of great books that are helpful to other people.
And how do you reconcile that
with being present for the people that you care about?
If you wanna write the absolute best book
to your maximum capabilities,
that's gonna require time away
from the people that you love.
Right?
So when those two things are butting up against each other,
I think that's where confusion ensues.
And the only way through
is just to pay super close attention as you go
and then update, because at different times of your life,
the answer in the moment to,
"What do I do in this situation?" is gonna be different.
And I firmly believe
that there's no such thing as a bad decision.
The only wrong way to go about a decision
is without being thoughtful,
paying attention, and being aware.
Because you can't know when you make that decision,
what the right thing is to do.
But if you just do it on autopilot,
that's when get into trouble.
Because if you're paying attention,
then your mind body system,
like the algorithm will update
based on what you get out of it.
But it's when we get on autopilot,
when we get just swept up
into the inertia of go, go, go, go,
whatever direction that it's pushing us in,
that's when we can get ourselves into trouble.
Sure.
Cause we're acting impulsively and reactively
without taking that moment to pause and reflect
and calibrate our behavior against that value set
or what is most important.
And, and also in realizing that
often it doesn't feel good in the moment
to act in alignment with your values.
Particularly around success and excellence,
there's like a very addictive nature to those feelings
of creating, of pushing, of being relevant.
And you could argue to yourself,
I know you've talked about this a lot on this podcast,
you could argue to yourself,
"Well, it's a wholesome endeavor I'm doing,"
but deep down inside, if you pay close attention,
like you can kind of discern,
"Is there a compulsive nature to this pushing?
Or am I doing this
because I genuinely want to in the moment?"
It's both.
Yes.
I got into a little thing with my wife this morning
because she noticed that I'm not as grounded
as I probably should be.
And she's a pretty good mirror.
Yeah.
You know, and she let me know like, "Hey,
I don't think that you're really on your game right now."
Cause I've been working a little bit too hard
and I'm juggling a bunch of stuff and, she's right.
I'm, this is like, as long as I've been doing this,
like I'm as guilty as anybody of, you know,
falling prey to external reward systems
and the habit trail of like, "Okay, what's next.
I gotta keep this thing going and how is it doing?"
and all of that.
And I lose sight
of the values that are most important to me, which is,
"Can I be present with my wife and my kids in the morning
before I go off and do this thing with Brad today?
Or am I obsessed with
making sure I'm as prepared as possible
and not present for the people that I care about?"
But that's it. So you're winning the game.
Like just having that trade off
and being aware of it
and evaluating-
But,
self-awareness, you know, as they say,
self-awareness will sell you nothing.
Like it's, like, it's good that you understand that,
but until you actually behave differently,
you're still stuck in the negative cycle.
Yes.
And I think that you need the self-awareness
to be able to realize that,
"Hey, these are two competing values
and I'm feeling a real tension."
And then that gives you the opportunity
to kind of force yourself to maybe act in one way,
even if, in the moment,
the inertia is carrying you in the other way.
The recurring kind of motif
that anchors these principles around groundedness
that recurs in the book is this idea of being a redwood.
So explain that,
and then we can kind of get a little bit more granular
into the kind of six aspects
of what it means to pursue this.
So, I had the idea for the book,
but I had no idea what I was gonna call it.
And I was out for a hike with a dear friend
in Redwood Regional Park.
This is back when I was living in Oakland, California.
And it was a super gray, windy, day.
It's always like that
in Oakland-
Right, it's true.
And the overstory of these trees,
they were just swaying back and forth.
And I remember telling my friend, Mario, you know,
Mario Frailly.
Yeah.
I remember telling Mario like, "Man,
like, that's kind of like how I feel a lot of the time."
He's like, "Me too."
I'm like, "Yeah."
And he had known about this book. He's a good friend.
We brainstorm all the time and I'm like, "Yeah."
I'm like, "That's kind of what I'm getting to in the book,
like, heroic individualism is a lot of this."
And I'm like, "But look at the fricking core of those trees,
like it is just held firm to the ground;
really grounded.
And that's when the light bulb went off. I'm like,
"Huh, like maybe I should call this grounded,
groundedness, get grounded, whatever."
So then like the writer intellectual brain in me is like,
"I wanna learn more about redwoods."
And the first thing I learned about redwoods,
to this day remains the most fascinating,
which is that even the old growth redwoods,
that tower 200, 300 feet above the ground,
their root structures only run six to 12 feet deep,
But they're intertwined-
like laterally.
Bingo.
Yeah.
They're laterally,
they run for hundreds of feet and they're intertwined
with all the other roots of other trees in the forest.
So what holds a redwood up through really rough weather
is not it's trunk that you see,
it's this deep stuff that's underground,
but it's only as deep is it is lateral
because it's held together by a community of other trees.
And that then became the metaphor for grounded,
for groundedness, is both
this notion that when the weather is really rough,
what kind of foundation do you have
holding you to the ground?
And these are often qualities that people don't see.
So it's not the beautiful overstory
or even the big firm trunk,
it's stuff that's invisible
and it's only as powerful
as the trees that you're intertwined with,
which of course is why
community is arguably the most important
of the six principles in the book.
Right.
(upbeat drum music plays)
Standing in your strength, being unflappable,
being neutral in the face of catastrophe and conflict,
et cetera.
How do we achieve that? Right?
We achieve that through community.
That's one of the pillars here,
but let's break it down because I think it,
it has a nice flow to it,
in how you think about this and write about this.
All right, let's do it. Where do you wanna start?
Well, the first one is acceptance, which is like,
that's also like a big recovery thing, right?
You cannot, whatever you're going through,
you cannot get better until you snap the denial
and take an honest accounting of where you actually are,
which is very scary.
We have all these defense mechanisms
and excuses that we tell ourselves to allow ourselves
to perpetuate whatever it is that we're doing.
And we're very good at deluding ourselves as human beings.
So acceptance, you can't,
you can't really progress anywhere until you get real
about the truth of your current situation, professionally,
interpersonally, whatever it is.
So talk to me about how you kind of arrived at this
and how you think about it.
So I love how you, you teed that up.
And the only thing that I would add to that context
is back to heroic individualism being a cultural issue.
Everything in the culture tells us not to accept reality.
You know, you don't feel good.
There's a substance for that.
You can go buy some stuff.
You can tweet. You can post.
We're constantly kind of like living in this world
that allows us to distract ourselves
from whatever the reality might be.
But of course, if you can't accept where you are,
then you're never gonna get where you wanna go, right?
Because you'll be working on the thing
that isn't actually the thing that you need to be working on
because you're slightly deluded
or you're refusing to see it clearly.
Now a lot of people hear acceptance
and they think passive resignation, or phoning it in,
or like, "I'm not gonna try,"
but that is not at all what acceptance means,
at least not in the way that I conceptualize it.
It is actually very empowering because as it tells you,
here's exactly what's going on, here's the situation I'm in,
and then that gives you the opportunity
to take some sort of wise action
to progress the situation or make it better.
Right.
And the more type A and driven you are,
the more difficult it is for you to reckon with acceptance,
because you're the person who says, "I do not accept this.
I am working towards this. This is not okay.
And I will not stop until this happens."
And you just plow forward with blinders on.
And the idea of acceptance is akin to surrender.
And that's absolutely the last thing
that I'm going to even entertain.
Yes.
And I think that also what can be really helpful
in less extreme context,
so yes, surrender in my case, right?
Trusting Brooke with the knife, and being like,
"I don't, anything to get me out of here.
I'm done. I'm lost,"
Hitting bottom, as someone
that is suffering with a substance abuse disorder,
but also just surrendering to reality that,
"Hey, I'm way too overworked,"
or, "I'm not living in alignment with my values,"
or, "This relationship isn't what I thought it would be,"
or, "I'm not giving enough into this relationship,"
it's really hard to get there.
So a couple things that are super concrete and very helpful,
and they all relate to this concept
that's called self-distancing.
So we tend to fuse, "I'm gonna do this for the camera
so I'm not in front of the microphone here.
We tend to fuse with our circumstances.
And when you fuse with your circumstance,
it's very hard to see it clearly.
Meaning self-identify.
Yes, like instead of watching the action movie,
we're in the action movie.
And when things are going really well,
you wanna be in the action movie,
that's flow, that's a peak experience,
like you don't wanna be separate from your lived experience,
but sometimes when things aren't going so great,
or even if they are,
it can be really helpful to create some space
between your awareness of happening
and what's happening itself.
Right.
You did a Twitter thread on this recently,
you know, a way of translating that is by saying,
you know, rather than saying,
"I am depressed," saying,
"I am somebody who is experiencing depression," right?
Creating that little gap or that distance
so you disassociate or, you know,
deconstruct the self-identification
and then you're able to evaluate the situation
that you're in
and your behavior from a more objective perspective.
Yes.
And that is just one of many ways to self-distance.
Another way that I think is super powerful,
is this notion of pretending that a really close friend
is in the same exact situation that you are,
and really visualizing it down to a T,
and then giving that friend advice.
And then you have to
follow that advice-
We're all so much better
at that than-
Bingo!
Or imagine a wiser, older, version of you
looking back on current you,
what would wiser, older, you tell you?
So an extreme example of this,
but I just freaking love this story
is, I was working with a woman who's a world-class runner,
professional runner, multiple time Olympian.
And she had a proximal high-hamstring strain
and she was trying to train through it.
And she's like hobbling down the steps of her apartment
to go do a mile repeat workout.
So for the uninitiated, this is like a ball-busting,
I guess, in her case not so, but a really hard workout.
And I'm not coaching her on her running,
I'm there to, you know, provide like mental skill support.
And I remember saying,
I'm gonna call her Rachel for the sake of the story,
"Rachel, imagine that your training partner
was in this situation,
and you saw your training partner, Elise,
hobbling down the stairs,
kind of grasping at her hamstring on the way out the door
to do an interval workout.
What would you tell her?"
And she's like, "I'd tell her not to do the workout.
Like she's just gonna blow herself up.
It's okay to go off the plan.
I'd tell her it's better to miss a day or two now
than it is to miss a month later."
Like,
well then why on earth are you going to do this workout?
Cause you don't understand Brad.
Well, no.
I can make this work.
Yes, and, I think that
when you give that advice to someone,
you very quickly see that,
like you can't make it work.
This isn't a coaching session,
but in your situation with like feeling ungrounded
and you being like, "Well, I have these competing values.
It's really hard to know which one to prioritize."
I think in that instance,
if you could imagine yourself 30 years down the road,
looking back on current you, in that situation,
it might give you some insight for at least for today
like, "Hey, here's the decision that I should make."
Yeah.
It's not bulletproof, but, again, what it does
is it takes this, I'm fused with the situation.
I'm in an Olympic cycle.
I need to train. It's on my plan.
I'm so caught up in the storm
and it puts you here so that you can watch the storm
and then gives you a chance to make
a more thought-
Right.
thoughtful decision.
On the subject of acceptance,
the path towards acceptance is paved with pain, right?
Pain is like the great catalyst
for this awakened self-awareness,
Often.
and the ability to develop acceptance
around what's occurring.
In your case,
it was a much more severe case of OCD than I realized.
In my case, it was grappling with addiction,
and you know, later in life with some health stuff.
Short of experiencing some kind of extreme, you know,
emotional experience or,
you know what we would call a bottom in recovery,
you can grow into this level of acceptance
around whatever it is you're doing.
It's just harder, right?
Like pain really makes it, as painful as it is,
it actually makes this whole process easier.
Yes.
It's like an, it, it creates an opportunity
or it helps that door swing wide open.
And I'm interested in the coaching that you do with people,
like they're probably not hitting a bottom.
They're probably high performers
who are just trying to, hone their game a little bit more,
maybe are experiencing
some things that aren't working in their life.
But you know,
they're not bottoming out on drugs and alcohol or,
you know, having some, suicidal ideation.
So how do you coach somebody
towards a greater level of acceptance
who's not in that position?
I mean, you just gave an example,
but what's another way that you would think about that?
Hmm.
Well, another great example is
just having a coach, or
in the case of someone that may not have access to that
is other people that you can trust, right?
Because if you can't see the world clearly
well go ask someone that you trust and,
it's gotta be someone that is willing
to tell you-
the real feedback.
The real deal.
So it's just ways to get outside of yourself a little bit.
And I do think that, yes,
deep pain can be a gateway to acceptance.
No one gets through life unscathed:
everyone experiences some pain.
And I'll tell you what,
like before I got sick with OCD, I thought like, you know,
getting dumped by my college girlfriend was pain
or having a book flop was pain.
Like in, based on my reference point, that was real pain.
So as a coach, when someone comes to you
with what they're experiencing is pain,
I have to be totally nonjudgmental
because I might be thinking like, "That's not real pain."
But to that person, it is.
So anytime that you meet a barrier,
there's some suffering, or there's some tension,
or sense of disconnect, I think is a pathway to explore,
"Well, what's really going on here?
What's the actual problem that we're trying to solve?"
Right.
And reframing pain
or whatever difficult experience you're enduring
as an opportunity,
like where is,
where is the learning experience in all of this to grow?
Yeah.
The only thing I'd say there
is, back to non-dual thinking,
I wouldn't say as an opportunity, but,
and an opportunity, because pain sucks.
And like, I'm not one to paint suffering as positive;
like suffering sucks.
Like the less that you suffer, the better.
And suffering exists, and, it's gonna happen inevitably,
so when it happens, yes,
there's also an opportunity along with it.
Right.
Can you look at it as a,
It's both.
as a teacher?
Yeah, both and, like this sucks, and it's a teacher.
And sometimes that has to happen on its own
and it has to happen later, because one of the worst things
that you can do when you're in pain
is put this another expectation on yourself to like,
it has to be meaningful.
Yeah. That's a good point.
And I did this,
I'm A type a pusher.
I remember, you know, I don't know, three,
four months into my recovery, being like,
"I don't feel like I'm growing from this
and it has to be meaningful.
And I don't think I'm ever gonna write about this."
At the time, and again, I remember my therapist, Brooke,
looking at me and being like, "Why the hell do you care?
Like this doesn't have to be meaningful.
You have severe OCD. It just sucks.
Can that be enough?"
And of course, now, a couple years later,
we're talking about it, I did write a book:
it's super meaningful.
It's probably, you know,
shy of like falling in love and having a kid,
it's by far, maybe even on the same level,
most meaningful experience in my life.
But when I was in it, utterly meaningless.
That means,
and that's okay.
the meaning isn't revealed immediately.
It's only in time.
Right.
And the psychologist, Daniel Gilbert talks about
like how we all have a psychological immune system
and you can't fake it.
So when you're really suffering, if you're like, "Oh,
I'm gonna grow from this," your psychological immune
system's like.
Like, "We just need to fight this and get rid of this pain."
But then afterwards, like the real immune system,
it gets stronger.
Like an immune system doesn't get stronger
as it's fighting the thing, it gets stronger after.
So yes,
sometimes you can reframe pain as like a growth opportunity.
And that might be the pain of a minor business failure,
or something in a friendship,
or a creative endeavor gone sour,
but illness, death, loss, I often think
that it's actually just okay to meet it where it is,
and then let the meaning and growth happen on its own time.
Which leads into the next pillar here, which is presence.
Like, can you just be present with what is happening?
Yes.
In acceptance, and present with it.
I don't know if I can. And it depends on the day.
(Brad laughing)
It's pretty tough.
It's tough.
And yet I'm gonna, I'm gonna kind of, I'm gonna get real
and in the moment on this table,
so I'm as present as I've been,
I don't know, in the last week, right now?
What's not on this table?
What do you mean?
There's no cell phone, right?
There's no Twitter.
No.
If I need to write something down,
I've got a notebook and a pen.
I think that we think of presence as this internal quality,
which it can be, but it's also very external.
So a huge part of presence
is putting yourself in situations
where it's easy to be present.
I often think that presence happens
upstream of the moment that you wanna be present.
I know you recently had Johan Hari on.
That was a great episode.
And he talked about like telling someone not to itch
I think it was, if like you pour itching sauce on them
and like the distractions in our life's the itching sauce.
So back to core values,
if one of your core values is presence
or related to things that you care about,
well, then you have to be pretty intentional
about setting up the time, and space, and conditions,
to be present.
Something else that I talk about all the time
with coaching clients that wanna be more present
is there's a reason that monks that achieve enlightenment;
they're all in monasteries.
Cultivating an environment
that's conducive to-
Yeah, like,
being present,
Yes.
But what about the relationship
between presence and groundedness?
Particularly in the context of like
working with very driven people,
presence feels like an indulgence,
it feels like an obstacle in the way of achieving
whatever you need to get done on a particular day
so you have to sell the bill of goods
as to why this is important.
Time out.
You said on a particular day, and that's the thing,
deep presence, and really like honing that
is never going to get you
the most work done on a particular day, ever,
but it might over the a course of a year,
or a decade, or a career, and the,
The tortoise,
the tortoise over the hare.
Yes.
And that's how you settle that score, right there.
I'm super clear with my coaching clients.
They come to me talking about
efficiency, and productivity, and optimization,
and I'm like, "All these things are great.
I want all these things too, but on what time scale?"
Because if I wanted to optimize over the next 24 hours,
or even over the next week let's say,
I would slam espresso and Red Bulls,
I'd sleep four hours a night,
and I would just bury myself and that'd be super optimal,
but not for a month, certainly not for a year.
So I think that there's a zooming out and saying,
"Hey, like what timescale are we operating on?"
And there, the research is unequivocal.
If you're talking about excellence or success
over the long haul
being present for the work that actually matters
is perhaps the most important variable
that you can do to set yourself up for that success.
Right.
We don't intuitively think about these horizons
in decade long chunks,
we think about the next quarterly earnings,
or the next six months are perhaps the next year
but if you really want to build sustainability,
which is what is at the core of what this is all about
like,
A hundred percent.
how do you wanna operate to the best of your ability
for the longest period of time?
You have to broaden that window, right?
And I've had to learn this, like I'm, you know,
I just want to grind and grind and grind.
And I've been doing this podcast for almost 10 years.
It became pretty clear like two years ago,
like I'm not gonna make it,
like I have to figure out a different way of doing this
so that I can maintain my joy for it
and my presence when I'm sitting with guests
and my enthusiasm for, you know,
consuming all of their wisdom and material
and being able to deliver on the best experience,
conversational experience that I can,
I can't sustain it the way I was doing it.
So now I take a month off every year,
I've hired a team and like, I've, I've had to learn how to,
you know, overcome this perfectionism and control impulses.
And those were not easy lessons for me.
And I'm not great at them every day either,
but it was like a necessity, I think,
in order to do that which gets into,
we're sort of moving out of presence
and more into the next thing, which is, which is patience.
Yeah. And I think built into patience
is this idea of looking at things, you know,
on a longer timeframe.
Yeah.
Real quick: I jotted a note down.
Did you, during that period,
and we don't have to name (indistinct)
but did you ever find yourself resenting
the fact that you had to come in and talk to someone?
It never got that bad, but I was moving in that direction.
And, and I really never wanted to feel that way.
And I realized that if I didn't change some things
that I was quickly gonna be that person.
And obviously, that's at odds with
the experience that I'm trying to cultivate and create.
I asked that because that emotion is often,
in my coaching clients, a game changer
for helping people realize that
their work style is too frenetic and frantic,
too "optimized," on short time scales,
is, people come to resent work that they once loved,
and the only thing that's changed about the work
is that when they started doing it,
they were a team of one and they had a really low bar
and they spent most of their day deep in the creative work,
and now suddenly they're running meetings
and they're leading teams,
and that deep focus, present work has gone away
and they start to resent their job.
And the number one thing to help those people,
are to help them reclaim those moments of presence.
And I'll say one more thing on this
before moving on to patience,
cause I think it's a very important coaching insight
and that is that it unequivocally you will fail
if you just say, "I wanna be more present."
And even if you try to work top down, you'll likely fail.
So to say like, "I need to be present all the time,"
it's never gonna work; there's too many distractions.
So with clients, I always have folks work bottom up.
So that means just start with two hours a week.
So schedule ahead of time, two, one hour blocks
where you know what you're gonna do during that period
so when it rolls around, you don't just pull up your email
and just start there.
And then after two weeks, try an hour and a half.
And I had this one client who came to me
because of feeling resentment and just like
coming to hate a job that she loved.
And at first I'm like, yeah,
maybe it's the job actually, and she needs to move on,
but it quickly became clear
that she actually loved the work,
she just didn't love how she was running around frantically.
And she said, there's no way she could be present.
She's high up. She runs this huge team.
She's got kids, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And we just started with an hour a day
and slowly but surely, she proved to herself
that the world wasn't gonna end
if for an hour a day, she put everything away and worked.
And a year into our coaching relationship,
this is a true story
I, and I try to practice what I preach.
So I am very,
I have boundaries around when I coach.
It's like certain days, certain times. And I went to try to
work with her executive assistant to get a coaching slot,
And the person's like, "No, like, sorry,
like Kate can't meet with you then, her afternoons
are all blocked off.
her window
and your window didn't,
So she went from impossible to be present
at a company with over a thousand people
to three and a half to four hours a day.
But it started,
if I would've told her that at the beginning,
she would've fired me.
And I think the same is true with ourselves.
Even if you don't have a coach, individually,
if you tell yourself,
"Oh, I'm gonna be present for four hours," and you fail,
it's like a diet.
It's like anything, when you're off the wagon,
it's hard to get back on.
So I think starting really small, and again,
it's a common theme in this book,
and I think this is the coach in me, is that
you take something that's really noble and aspirational,
but for it to work,
you've gotta get super concrete
and start at a level that is like in the weeds.
So I just wanted to add that in.
Yeah.
I think, in furtherance of that idea
is the notion of just being really granular.
You're gonna cultivate an environment
that's conducive to you being present,
but what does presence actually look like?
In sobriety, it's talked about in the context of
what is the next right action?
Like if you're just fully present with yourself,
meaning how do you overcome the overwhelm
of all these different competing stressors
that are in our mind?
"Oh, I have to do that. I gotta do that.
How am I gonna solve that problem?"
Okay. What's the next right action?
What is the one thing I can do right now?
I will just do that thing.
Not worry about anything else,
because truly, all we can do is one thing at a time.
How can we show up a hundred percent for that one thing
and move to the next thing?
Yep.
And just pay close attention along the way
because like the attention, that's the feedback mechanism.
Because I think that our like deeper,
wiser, removed selves, know what's good for us.
So I'm know that I feel so much better
after a day spent writing and reading
than a day on social media.
Right.
But then you will then construct a million distractions to,
(Rich laughs)
Yeah. So this-
way prevent you
from doing that thing.
And it's like, and then you beat yourself up.
"Why am I doing this? I know better."
I actually wrote a book about
how to not do this, and here I am doing it.
Ah."
But that's, but that's where
it's gotta get really concrete.
So like what does it look like?
It looks like taking the apps off your phone.
I mean, it's all of these very,
these concrete practices and remembering again,
like behavioral activation that you don't have to feel like
you wanna do something to do it,
you often just have to do the thing.
All right. Talk to me about the patience piece.
Yeah.
We were talking about this offline a little bit
before we started recording
cause I think it just occurred to me walking in seeing you
you're like the perfect example of this in many ways.
I don't feel that way.
Yeah?
Yeah.
All right.
Well-
I'm pretty impatient,
on the moment to moment basis.
But over the long haul?
So the study that we were joking about,
that's in this chapter of the book
was performed by researchers at MIT and Northwestern.
And they looked at successful entrepreneurs,
judged by company valuation
and in companies' IPOs, the ideal price,
and what they found to everyone's surprise
is that the peak age for a successful startup founder is 45.
Which just flies in the face of like, you know,
Super calm, the dropout.
We crashed all of these narratives
where these very young people are achieving
crazy heights of success at a very young age.
Yes.
And the reason for that, researchers speculate,
is that when you're 45,
well, you've failed a couple of times,
you've got some wisdom behind you,
and you can put that to bear at what you're doing.
The way that I like to think about this
is there's these two curves
that I think applies to anything that you're doing,
broadly speaking.
And one is what I call
quickness, cleverness, raw talent, intelligence,
I think a cognitive scientist
called this fluid intelligence.
So you're quick, you're sharp on your feet,
if you're an athlete, you're physically like,
as fit as you're gonna be.
And that curve declines as we age,
but there's this other curve which is wisdom
and wisdom increases as we age.
And I think every pursuit
has a meeting point of these curves
and the slopes are different, right?
And like if you're running the 100 meter dash,
the wisdom curves not as important as the raw talent curve.
Right.
Whereas if you're doing an ultra marathon,
the wisdom curve and the ability to problem solve
and have pattern recognition is super important.
And in an intellectual pursuits,
we often like overvalue the quickness curve
and undervalue the wisdom curve curve,
which I think is why that study was so surprising.
We assumed that people peak 25 to 30, 35,
when they're super fresh and quick on their feet,
but we discount that wisdom curve.
So I, we got into that cause we were talking about that,
but that's just like, that's one example where, again,
you zoom out, well, do you wanna be efficient today
or do you wanna be efficient over the long haul?
What is that at mean?
And it's a real tension.
In my own work, I'm constantly asking myself, you know,
in the moment, I think even when we were talking
about coming on to do the show, I'm like,
"I don't know if I'm gonna write a book
that's better than this."
So I can be really futile, but it's like,
"No, if I'm not an idiot, I will
because I'm gonna get wiser,
hopefully if I like live my life and experience the world,
so the patience to hold back, knowing that, yes,
you're building up that curve
and it goes totally against
this cultural narrative of you have to be young.
Right.
You've written about Darwin.
And we all think that he just, you know,
went down to the gala Galapagos and just figured it all out.
Right, in 25 years
In truth that was 25 years
for him to truly figure it out.
And contrasted him or not contrasted,
well, I guess compared and contrasted him
with another one of these overnight breakthroughs,
Ta-Nehisi Coates.
I mean, I was surprised
to learn that-
He'd been writing
for a long time.
Dude had been writing for 15 years. No one knew about him.
Like could hardly afford food and rent
and then suddenly he's this breakthrough
and he's got this be a quote where he
is like, "I'm not a breakthrough.
Like I was pounding that stone for 15 years."
Which is the case, of course,
with every overnight success that we see,
there's a deeper story that tells the truth
about the hard, well-trodden path to get to that place.
And you know,
I think the patience piece
is complicated by external social factors.
Like we're all in this rat race
where we think if we take a day off,
we're falling behind and if we fall behind,
we'll never be able to catch up.
And then the whole game is over with.
Like the insanity of that, you know,
habit trail that we're all on, when in truth,
like that's why I put that tweet out that I put it out
that, you know, everyone seemed to like,
that's pinned on my thing,
that, you know, life's longer than,
life's short, but it's actually long.
Steven Pressfield talked about this on the podcast.
Like, "It's kind of long," you know,
"You need to go out and have lots of different experiences."
And like David Epstein talks about in, "Range,"
try many, many, many things,
most of which you'll probably be shitty at,
but ultimately you'll find
that thing that lights you up.
And then you'll realize by pursuing that,
that all those other experiences find a way
to contribute to, you know, deepening your enrichment
in whatever the thing is exciting you.
And then suddenly you're the one person
who can do this very specific thing
because of all these rich experiences that you've had,
while you were experiencing them,
not knowing that they were contributing to, you know,
you becoming this, you know,
kind of unique, actualized person.
Yeah.
There's a mindset tool that I,
I just fricking love in the book
about D.W. Winnicott, the psychoanalyst
from the mid-20th century.
And I'm a huge fan of Winnicott's work in parenting.
And his whole parenting philosophy
is what he called the good enough mother.
And I'm gonna update it for today's time.
I'm gonna call it the good enough parent.
And long before helicopter parenting was a thing
Winnicott observed that there's two extremes of parenting.
There's the parents that meet a child every need,
all the time and hover,
and then there's parents
that check out and neglect the child
and both of those lead to bad outcomes.
The ideal parent, Winnicott said is the good enough parent.
And he defined the good enough parent
as someone that creates a space for their kid to unfold.
And when their kid steps off that path
or veers too far out of that space,
they gently nudge them back into it.
And I remember reading that as I was working on this book
and thinking like, A,
that's our new mantra for parenting in our household
is like, let's just be good enough.
And B, what if we adopted that mindset with our own selves
and the projects in our lives?
So what would it look like to think of ourselves
not as constantly needing
to intervene and make everything happen,
but to provide a space
for our pursuits to unfold on their own?
So how can we be good enough to ourselves?
How can we take that mindset
and apply it to our own pursuits?
And.
How's that working?
You know, I was gonna say,
for me it's actually working pretty well.
Like I think there's real power
in giving something a language
because then you can name it
and make it real and wrestle with it.
So when I catch myself like getting into that
need to make things happen mode,
I just ask myself like,
"Am I hovering? Am I being a helicopter parent,
for my next book, for my podcast,
for my newsletter, whatever it is
and what would it look like to be good enough?
And sometimes the answer is, "No, you need to push.
You need to make things happen."
But often that pause
gives me a chance to actually step back and say,
"You know, this is gonna work itself out."
Or, "I need to give this a little bit more time and space."
For us as creatives, I think that this is really helpful.
I think it's even more helpful
for people that work in the traditional workplace
because most people, at least in my experience coaching,
they get into these executive roles
because they were phenomenal at making things happen.
That's how they get noticed.
They get work done, especially in big organizations.
It's like, "Oh,
you're the person that can actually like get the work done."
So then you get promoted, you get promoted.
And now
suddenly you have a team of a thousand people under you.
Guess what?
Like that sensibility of making everything happen
is not gonna work.
You've gotta learn to step back and let things happen.
And the whole job becomes like the conductor of an orchestra
or the good enough parent.
You're just kind of defining the space
and keeping everyone in it.
And so many people hit this wall
where they continue to try to make things happen
when they need to step back and play that role.
Well, also the skill changes.
They go from somebody who is a doer and making stuff happen,
into this role as being a manager,
which requires some emotional intelligence
and some background in psychology
to figure out how to motivate people
and get them to do their best work and all of that.
Like it's a completely different skillset.
And it requires a lot of confidence and security
cause the worst managers are super insecure
and they think they always need to be doing stuff, right?
No different than probably a helicopter parent
that like is insecure if
their kid's not gonna turn out great
if they don't do everything.
Right.
Or an individual working on a project?
Like generally overdoing something
is a sign of our own insecurity.
It's the athlete that in her case,
has to go out and run a really hard workout
to prove to herself that she's still fit,
that's born out of insecurity.
So I think that also part of being a good manager
is having the security to know that, "Hey, I don't,
there's no visible observable concrete thing
I necessarily need to do.
I just need to, again,
define the at space and then hold it
for my team to do their thing."
And that's where just like just the word,
like, "Be good enough,"
has been so powerful with clients
cause it serves as this little cue
to step back and ask themselves,
"Like what are we really trying to do here?"
One of the challenges with patience,
if you're somebody who is ambitious,
you're inevitably going to be comparing your,
your trajectory to other people, right?
And, and here's Brad, who's telling you,
"Slow it down a little bit, be present,
be patient, life is long,
don't worry about what those other people are doing."
It's easier to say that
than to actually embody that and practice that.
So, how do you help people disconnect
from that kind of external motivation or pressure
of comparing yourself to others?
Back to the core values.
So all these things are entangled, right?
So then you go look at your core values
and how you define them and how you practice them
and just say like, "Well,
what would living my core values be in this moment?"
And then you just do it, you know,
behavioral activation, like you,
you don't have, in that moment,
you probably don't feel like you should slow down.
You probably feel like you should speed up.
But I think the core values
like that becomes your internal dashboard.
So ideally you're not spending as much time
comparing yourself to everyone else,
you're spending more time comparing yourself
against your core values and measuring yourself that way,
and then letting that guide your actions and your behaviors.
It's a tough shift.
I mean we moved from Northern California, big city, airport,
tons of opportunities to talk about books and sell books
and build a coaching practice,
to a small mountain town in Western North Carolina.
And it was tough
and that was a hundred percent a values-based decision.
But in the moment, that move was like, "What am I doing?
Like I'm not gonna sell as many books."
But like it, it made not, it didn't it,
the inertia of the moment and speed did not make sense,
but from a values perspective, it made sense.
And it didn't feel great making that decision,
but now that we've done it, it actually feels really good
but there's a real trade off.
Would I be "more successful" externally
if I still lived in the Bay Area?
Maybe, probably at this young age,
but would I be successfully against my internal dashboard?
Probably not.
Right.
Well, the counter argument would be
that by living in a smaller town, there's less distractions.
So the actual work of writing the books
and the frequency of these books coming out
is gonna be enhanced.
And ultimately that's the larger lever to your success.
If you're in Oakland, maybe you can go on more podcasts.
Maybe you can talk about it a little bit more
and be more engaged with media and promotion.
But ultimately, over the long run,
the thing that matters most is the quality of the work
and creating an environment that's conducive to that
is the key thing that aligns the values with, you know,
the actual like byproduct of your actions.
A hundred percent.
And you said long run like two times in that sentence.
Cause again, it's patience: it's playing the long game.
But I didn't get there, like out of this esoteric value,
I got there because my wife and I said, "What do we about?
We care about nature. We care about family.
We care about love.
Well what would it look
like to practice those things in Oakland
versus in a smaller town?"
And it was a very like somewhat rational decision
that now it has this huge emotional benefit, which is,
I feel like I can play the long game.
You'd think I'd get more writing done,
but I walk out the door,
hit the trails with my German Shepherd.
If anything, I'm a professional walker now.
Do a lot of long walks.
Without any audio? Just solo?
It depends.
I go back and forth.
Sometimes I'll listen to your podcast
because I don't really commute so it is my time
if I'm gonna listen to a podcast.
Sometimes I'll listen to like Vivaldi or classical music.
I listen to Dispatch,
who I was so shocked that you hadn't heard of.
I'm an old man, Brad, come on, give me a break.
Those guys are old.
I listen to REM, and, Radiohead,
and like a couple other bands and that's like it.
I'm stuck in my ways.
Yeah. Dispatch, came a little bit later, but not much.
I bet those guys are like 49, you know,
they're peaking right now.
Their songs are so wise. Go check 'em out.
I'll check them.
But yeah, so, so, so yes, it all loops back.
Like all these things are integrated and in that case,
the patience and the core values go hand in hand.
But if you don't have that internal dashboard,
then you're gonna be sucked up into the rat race,
into measurement, into speed.
And it's not either/or,
most people live in both these worlds every day,
maybe even every hour.
So the game is just trying to, again,
realize when you're in the world that you don't wanna be in
and then have some tools to get you back on the path.
One of those tools being the practice of vulnerability,
we talked earlier about you, you know,
writing about your OCD
and how important engaging in that vulnerability has been
in your journey and in your process.
But why is this like
one of the core principles of groundedness?
Well, I don't think that you can truly be strong
unless you are vulnerable.
And Brene Brown writes beautifully about vulnerability
and in particular, the benefits
of connecting with other people.
So, there's no point of me talking about that.
Y'all could just go listen to, read, Brene Brown.
Something that she doesn't speak about as frequently
is the benefits of being vulnerable with yourself,
for your ability to trust yourself.
And that is why vulnerability makes you stronger.
If you have parts of yourself that you don't explore,
that you're scared to explore,
that you kind of know are there, but you don't go there,
those parts of yourself tend to creep up and uproot you,
to stick to the groundedness metaphor.
There's this ancient Greek myth
that I just love about the god Pan.
And Pan lived just outside of the village boundaries.
And every once in a while, people would be
out hunting or foraging and they'd get lost
and they'd venture into the terrain of Pan,
and then they'd see Pan.
And he was so terrifying that as they ran away,
they would freeze outta fear and die.
Whereas in the myth, a few courageous villagers,
deliberately ventured out to go see Pan
and to the people that went to see him,
Pan bestowed upon them, wisdom, compassion, and strength.
And I read that
as just a beautiful metaphor for vulnerability.
So we all have our Pans, right?
These are like our cracks,
the parts of us that make us fragile.
And if we try to avoid them,
eventually we're gonna stumble into them
and it's gonna be ugly.
And there's a lot of projection that happens too I think.
Whereas if we can face them,
sometimes with the help of other people,
a therapist, a coach, more often than not a friend,
community members, family,
it actually makes us stronger.
Because it's very hard to trust all of yourself,
unless you fully know all of yourself.
Right.
But short of some kind of crisis,
it's easier to just live another day,
compartmentalizing all of those things
and not look at those things, rather than
continue to peel back the layer and peel back the layer.
And it's like, "Is this ever gonna end?"
There's no end to the amount of stuff
that's down there waiting to be excavated, Brad.
Yes/and-
It's exhausting-
And, it's back to both/and,
And? You, you, did you take improv classes?
No, why? Is that a thing?
Yes/and, is like the core of improv.
Really?
Yeah,
you do yes/and to everything.
Oh I love that/it.
You never say no, when get a prompt,
and I've noticed you, in this practice of yes/and,
which is good for conversation.
Yeah. I never knew it was an improv thing.
I always think of it, it's non-dual thinking
because I'm a firm believer that like
very few things are either/or; they tend to be both/and.
Or like in this context, versus that.
How do you survive Twitter with that, with that ideology?
I schedule a lot of my
tweets-
I say that as a joke,
like, no, somebody who appreciates nuance
and can see, you know,
The Twitter-
the Twitter
complexities of everything, the Twitter thread.
Cause Twitter's like your main thing.
Yeah. The Twitter thread function is nice now.
Like I do a lot more threads
where I actually explain things.
And Twitter is just, I mean, I'm being, and being raw.
I probably shouldn't say this.
Like Twitter is just a gateway
to have people hopefully discover my books, because like
that's where I really have
the time and space to explore this.
But a lot of people live there
so that's where I meet them.
But to your point about like how to do all of this?
Nondual.
Like the, if you, you were to spend your whole day
just peeling back that layer
and exploring your own mortality
and just all these things that are really hard,
you'd be like one of these existentialists
that ends up quite miserable.
But totally denying those things, also, I don't think,
is a ticket to a rich and textured life.
And you can't run away from them forever anyways.
Like eventually they catch up to you.
So it's about knowing them without harping on them.
And I think that most people by trying not to know them,
again, at some point like you come head to head with them
and that's when it becomes really hard to detach.
Yeah, the,
the war that I wage
is understanding these principles
and I practice vulnerability.
And I understand how that makes you
more able to connect with other people.
Like, I think there's this notion like,
"Oh, I'll make friends by, you know,
presenting the best version of myself
and those people will be impressed,
and they'll invite me into their friend group,"
when, of course it's the opposite.
It's only when you're honest and you can disarm people
with your level of like candor and self-reflection,
that's really the glue I think.
And I think I'm pretty good at that.
But I think what I do
is I fall into this pattern of tomorrow.
Like I know that like I gotta get through today.
I know all this groundedness stuff,
but like I got 10 things I gotta get through.
So I just can't like take that moment
to do that other thing that I know is good for me
and that's just gonna have to wait for another day.
And then that day becomes two days, becomes three days.
Yeah.
I mean, you say this on all your podcasts, man.
Like, "You just have to do it."
So it's back to like scheduling it, owning it,
not waiting, not needing to feel motivated to do it.
There might never be a good time,
but that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't put it on your calendar and do it.
And in this case, I don't know what that might be.
It might be like structured contemplation.
It might be biweekly session with a therapist.
It might be
scheduling time with a close friend to just dive deep.
I think that you sell yourself short.
I think that you get a lot of that in your work
because you get to have these conversations right now.
Like what are at least 70% of your podcast shows
if not peeling back
those layers?
Well, they're
self-serving in that regard
for sure-
But you
built it into your life, so you do do it.
I, I do.
And, it is true.
Like last night I had a therapy group meeting
that I have here every Monday night with a bunch of dudes.
But that means that I'm up later
and I don't get as much sleep.
And then today, because I had that last night,
I wasn't as prepared to talk to you today.
So I made decision to block out the morning
to make sure I was optimally prepared to talk to you.
Which meant that I didn't train today.
So there's so many moving pieces.
And for me it's about just being okay with the fact
that like, I'm not gonna get
every piece in the right place every single day.
And that's okay.
So not feed myself?
like transcend that,
that default setting
that is telling me that I failed
because I didn't do these three things
that I would've preferred to have done
because I had these other competing values
that took precedence on this particular day.
So what you just said to me
is a beautiful and very concrete example
of the self-compassion and self-discipline.
Because it takes a lot of self-discipline to do what you do.
But if you didn't have that self-compassion too,
you'd burn out.
Like imagine if you went into this,
and I'm sure there's still a part of you that's like,
"Damn it Rich, like you're off your schedule.
You didn't train,"
whatever-
Right.
I was like, "Oh, I should have
just woken up earlier and made sure I got my training in
and then I could have also done this."
But then, I have done that also,
but then I'm rushing from one thing to the next.
And yeah, I can check all those boxes,
but I'm less present for all of those things.
And I'm actually less fulfilled and happy
because it's always about, you know,
being on this ticking clock
and making sure that I get from point A to point B on time.
Another thing that I just noticed, and again, I know,
I know we're not coaching here,
is the word should is always a flag for me.
I say that a lot.
Yeah.
I know you-
talk about that so explain that.
Yeah. Don't should all over yourself.
When you catch yourself-
I constantly do that.
When you catch yourself shoulding, ask yourself,
can you replace it with a wish or a want?
And if the answer is no,
then maybe you shouldn't do that thing.
And if the answer is yes, then even that softens the tone.
So, "I wish I would've been able to exercise."
It's not nearly as judgemental.
There's a parable in Buddhism about the second arrow.
I love this too. I mean, I love all these parables,
cause there's so much truth in them.
And the, it goes like this.
The first arrow is something that we can't control
and it can be internal or external.
I used to think it was just external,
but OCD will teach you
that you cannot really control your thoughts.
So you could have an intrusive thought,
your schedule could get away from you, whatever it is.
And the first arrow hurts. It sucks.
But the second arrow, the third arrow, the fourth arrow,
all those additional arrows,
are your judgements about those things,
your repression of those things,
your shoulding on yourself.
And those arrows often hurt worse than the first arrow.
Right? It's the compound interest of negativity.
Yes.
Right?
Like you make the mistake
and then you beat yourself up for making the mistake
so you've just made a second mistake.
Yes. And you can't be perfect.
Again though, nondual.
Like, it doesn't mean that you should say,
"Well to hell with it all."
Or, "Let's all just hold hands and sing 'Kumbaya,'"
it means that, "Let's hold hands and sing 'Kumbaya,'"
and accept that we're not perfect."
And let's identify things that matter for us
and try to get better in, in stress.
Lot of like mid-century, George Leonard,
before him, Alan Watts, these kind of
self-fashioned gurus and philosophers of the good life,
many of whom have had a lot of good things to say,
they often talked about the wisdom of insecurity,
and that's an Alan Watts' term in particular.
And just how like accepting that you're not perfect
and being okay with that
is actually the key to getting better.
Because if you constantly hold yourself
to this bar of perfect,
like you're gonna just getting your own way all the time.
So that's another example of this nondual thinking
you can be both good enough, and get better.
You can be both loving to yourself,
and really hard on yourself.
On the subject of vulnerability,
I'm just putting myself in the shoes of,
let's say an executive at a corporation.
And he is listening to this, or she is listening to this
and thinking, "Okay, I understand that,
but I can't show vulnerability in the workplace.
That's gonna be the death knell.
My whole thing is to make sure
that everybody understands that I'm in charge.
I've got everything under control,
and that's how we, you know, push this train forward."
That's a really tricky situation.
And-
and I'm sure you
hear that a lot.
Yeah. It's a common one.
Yeah.
And the coaching tool that I use there is,
"Ask yourself what you really wanna say,
and then say something as close to that as possible."
So the there's a story here.
And one of my first coaching clients
was a woman who in the book I called Donna,
not her real name.
And she called herself the accidental executive.
So she had no goal of being an executive,
and sure enough, there she found herself
in the number three position
at a multinational organization with over 50,000 employees.
And she was the only woman on the 20th floor of headquarters
and the only Black person.
So she called herself the double only.
And she had so much imposter syndrome
and it was a real challenge for her.
And also probably thinking that
she doesn't have the liberty of being able to make mistakes.
Bingo. Because of being the double only.
So we talked about this
and she particularly froze up
when she was on like the corporate road show.
So overseas, giving talks about,
"Hey, here's the vision, here's the strategy,
here's how we're gonna do it."
She got really panicked.
She felt like she wasn't herself on stage.
So for a while
we tried just having her pretend that she was performing,
but that didn't work for her.
She's like, "But I, that's not me."
Like, "I'm a genuine person."
I'm like, "What do you really wanna say?"
And she looked at me, she's like,
"What I really wanna say is I have no idea how I got here.
I'm utterly overwhelmed.
And this is crazy."
Like, "Why don't you just say that?"
And to your point, she's like,
"I can't say that.
These people like were a publicly traded company,
like that'll be on the cover of the Wall Street Journal.
Like, I don't know how I got here."
But then I asked her cause she,
this was after my essay on OCD.
Like, "Well, you read what I wrote, right?
That was all over the place."
She's like, "Yeah.
I'm like, "Well, how did that make you feel about me?"
She's like,
"It's actually like
part of the reason I wanted to work with you."
I'm like, "Well, I clearly don't have it all together.
Like why would you wanna work with me? I'm a mess."
She's like, "No, like you're a human."
And I'm like,
"All right, so you can't say that
you have no idea what's going on,
but maybe you can get close to that?"
So ultimately she ended up going on stage
and she started to open up these talks
by saying that, "I feel like an accidental executive.
Sometimes I walk onto a stage like this
and I'm in awe of how I got here.
And it's a really challenging job
and I'm doing the best that I can.
And that's why it's so important
that I need all of your help and engage in the company
and this, that and the other."
And then everybody fell in love with her.
Everybody fell in love with her,
the reviews after the talks skyrocketed
and most important is she felt like herself.
So that's all it took.
Cause she knew she was.
When she went up there all corporate,
like, "These are the vision and values."
And, "I don't know what I'm talking about."
And I think that that's another truth
is that so many of us are making it up as we go.
In a way we all are. Some of us are just making it up
with a little bit more
experience and expertise than others.
So it's a long-winded answer to your question of,
for the person that's at setting,
I think the heuristic is,
"Ask yourself what you really wanna say
and then say as close to that as you're comfortable with."
Yeah.
It has to be gauged in accordance with the scenario
because the unhealthy extreme of this is either
the TMI-
Yep.
Or performative vulnerability,
which is a huge-
That's the other thing,
the performative vulnerability, which we see a lot of,
which is inauthentic vulnerability
for the purpose of gaming the system.
Correct.
In vulnerability, like that's the,
I read a Brene Brown book
and I know that more people will like me
if I'm vulnerable.
Or even worse, I'll get
more followers-
It's a good marketing,
on social media-
marketing strategy. Yeah.
Yeah. And, and that I get asked that question sometimes.
And the way that I like to think about it in my own life
is vulnerability should very rarely feel good in the moment,
especially if it's with other people.
So earlier, when you asked about my OCD,
my brain is always going through this,
"Well, like how deep should I go?
Should I talk about the knife thing?"
Like, I really don't like talking about that.
And that doesn't feel good.
Like that was not a fun part of this conversation for me.
And if, like, to me, that's the essence of vulnerability.
Like if I wanna live that value, it shouldn't feel good.
Whereas if I'm all calculating and I'm like,
"Oh, like that's gonna make,"
I don't, people are gonna,
a lot of people probably tune out at that point.
Like, "This guy's nuts."
But I think that that's like that for me is the barometer.
If you are doing vulnerability as a means to an end
or like you're scheming,
then you're probably
actually doing yourself more harm than good.
At some point,
if you're compelled to tell that story tons of times
cause you're doing lots of media and podcasts,
you'll probably end up in this place where I found myself,
which is telling the same story again.
And always trying to,
you know, be as honest as possible
and perhaps, you know, find a different way into it
or a different version of it or angle of it.
But I found myself telling a story that's true
and then wondering like, "Did that really happen?"
Because you, you end up disassociating with it
because you've told it so many times
and then you're like, and it doesn't have that same,
you don't feel like it's it's vulnerability because,
because it's so rote at that point
and then it feels rehearsed and almost flat.
And I'm like, "Did that even happen? Like it?
Or am I just remembering this?
Like what is the truth behind this?"
So then it becomes an exercise of like going deeper into it
and trying to find a way
to continue to stay emotionally connected with that thing
that was so formative and kind of,
you know, catalyzing journey that you've bet on.
And just painful.
Yeah.
And I think that's it, like if it feel,
and I don't, I don't, I, because
most podcasts don't go as beautifully deep as yours,
And I genuinely mean that,
you look at the podcasts I've been on they're shorter.
I tend not to be able to go deep
cause the last thing I wanna do is feel compressed for time.
So I'm fortunate that in a conversation like this,
I feel like I have the time to,
but ultimately like it's just a memory of like a lot of pain
and I think healthy healing is
there's gotta be some distance between how painful that was.
Cause otherwise it'd be hard to get through the day.
Sure.
So I also think that's probably
a sign of like good recovery,
is intellectualizing it enough,
but not so much that now
it's just this thing that you're talking about.
Right.
Let's talk about the community piece for a little bit.
The roots that run laterally.
I would imagine in your coaching practice,
there's a bit of a hurdle here
because the type A, driven person is also likely to be
the control freak, or,
"I'm the only one who knows how to do it this way.
Everybody just needs to listen to me
and the world will be perfect
and I can form it in my image."
Sound like my four year old.
(general laughter)
Right.
I sound like me, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah. So where to start with community?
I think the first thing is community is not efficient.
It is not "optimal," or productive in the short term.
Cause building community is slow.
It takes time and the best, deepest,
most nourishing communities are not those
that are means to an end, their ends in and of themselves.
And I think that's really important.
So there's building community because knowing these people's
gonna help you launch your product or fund your business,
and then there's just building community
for the sake of building community.
And what the research unequivocally shows
is that on our deathbeds, no one looks back and says,
"Oh, it's the gold medal."
Or, "It was the promotion to regional vice-president."
Everybody looks back and they
talk about the relationships they made along the way.
So I'm gonna give the answer for people
that are on this wavelength,
and then the answer for people that might be more
like me and you, which are like,
"Well, I need to be efficient. I need to be productive.
I need to push."
So for those that don't,
I think you're already like in a good spot
in terms of community.
It's just make that a goal, like build community,
put yourself out there, take the time to do that.
Maybe we'll talk a little bit about how.
For people like you and I, I think it's so important
that when you pick a goal,
the steps that you have to get there
should involve building community.
So like you bake it into your work.
Again, clearly you've done that with this podcast,
but try to make more and more things,
a team game, or a game of relationships,
or where you're building a community
as a part of this pursuit that you have,
or this passion that you have.
But ultimately the best community that I have
is like my actual neighbors and my neighborhood.
And I think some of this is probably the privilege of living
in an actual neighborhood in the small town.
But no one knows who I am.
Like, it's very easy for me.
You know? Like you.
Like, "Oh, well I'm this intellectual person.
And I need people like Rich
that I can talk about these topics with," you know,
Brandy and Evan next door, they don't really care;
they don't even know that I do this.
So there is zero means to an end,
but there's something that is just so viscerally,
like grounding about being in a space
and knowing your neighbors, and knowing the gossip,
and knowing that you all have each other's back
if something were to happen,
and having the dogs play in the backyard.
These small things that help us
to feel like this world isn't so big
and we're not so insignificant,
which if you live in the internet
is how you feel all the time
cause it's just infinity.
Whereas if you have a physical community,
then it becomes small.
It becomes manageable.
So a homework assignment that I have
for a lot of coaching clients and they don't like it
is like really try to get involved locally;
go to a city council meeting.
I mean, maybe not politically as a first step,
but you get my point like, like go to the farmer's market,
like start having these routines.
If you work from home and you're creative,
like pick two cafes and work at them.
And I used to be like this when I was like,
way back pre-OCD in my like too productive mode.
I remember distinctly like working on my first book.
And when I first started writing for Outside,
I was in my 20s, I was hungry, I thought I had to push,
I wouldn't wanna leave my apartment
because the commute to the cafe would take 10 minutes
and I might lose my train of thought.
That's where I was at.
I'm with you on that.
And now it's like, no, like you go to that cafe,
you learn the barista's name
because again, efficiency today, bust out the piece.
Long haul efficiency productivity
is being happy, feeling grounded,
and there's something really nice
about walking into a coffee shop and nodding,
and everyone knows you.
Right?
So again, it's ultimately about
understanding what's in your best interest long term
and being will willing
or having the kind of emotional fortitude
to delay or-
And short term though,
Or set aside the short term gain.
You know what I mean?
Yeah but it's also,
but yeah, but it's also short term
because I think it's-
because you're happier
throughout your day and your life is more rich.
Bingo.
And I think like we're such creatures of our surroundings.
So another example on community that,
that definitely, my guess, will resonate for listeners
that spend a lot of time on the internet
and other creatives out there.
So when I do not do a good job prioritizing community,
that is when I am most at apt
to feel insecure about myself as an author
and as a person on the internet,
that is when I will check the sales rank of my book.
That is when I will tweet more often
to try to get more followers.
I will do all of these things
to try to feel relevant against infinity.
When I am engaging in my community,
I find that the urge to do that, the thought to do that,
the feeling like I need to, it's zero.
It's not important.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
So you do feel better in the short term.
I think, at least I do.
And I know like I've gotten really good at paying attention.
So now when I catch myself like
searching for that relevance on the internet,
it simply means like, I look at my calendar,
I look what I did the last two weeks. It's like,
"Oh, I supposed to train with Tony on Saturday,
but I kind of flaked out on him
because I knew I only had 45 minutes
cause I wanted to write this thing
before Theo goes to soccer."
It's like, "No, the thing can wait."
Cause now I'm sitting there on Twitter,
hoping that people like the thing,
because I'm not feeling relevant
because I didn't make time for the community.
Talk to me about out the movement piece.
Yeah. I mean, you talk to me,
you know, better than anyone.
I mean, you know, I don't, you know, it's like, listen,
we're on the same page here.
We're on the same page here.
I can't, I can't be,
It's impossible,
a happy, functional, productive, human being
unless I'm moving my body
on the regular-
So this was,
this was a really interesting conversation with my,
my editor who I loved, which is
movement, at first,
felt disconnected from the other principles in this book,
at least to a lot of people at my publisher,
not to me-
Because why?
Because these other things are these like
very age-old, psychological principles,
and this is a perfect way into movement.
Cause most people, you and I hear movement
and we think probably more psychology than physiology.
Sure.
But most people hear movement and they think exercise,
they think, "What does exercise have to do
with vulnerability, or patience, or community?"
And the argument that I made to them
and then that I make in the book
is it actually has everything to do
with these other attributes.
So Rene Descartes separated the mind and body.
And that was a huge mistake.
And our thinking is still very much
in this-
Bifurcated body.
in this bifurcated mind-body thinking,
when in fact the latest research shows
that we are not a mind or body,
we're not even a mind and body:
we're a mind-body system.
And it would be intellectually dishonest for me
to talk about all these other principles and tools
and not include movement.
Because before I do any of the other work
with my coaching clients,
I help them develop a movement practice
if they don't have one.
And a movement practice doesn't
need to be cycling, or swimming, or CrossFit:
it can be gardening, it could be dancing, it could be yoga.
And what I find for most people
and actually what I do the most for myself right now
is just walking.
The benefits of a daily brisk walk
are just you're-
You're also Jack,
you're also pretty jacked up, right?
(general laughter)
So, so, so the shirt might be tight.
First thing when you walked in, I was like,
"Whoa, someone's been in the weight room
since the last time I saw you."
So, so I, in the spirit of full disclosure right now,
my physical practice looks like
four days a week I strength train for an hour
and I have a phenomenal coach that is just fun to work with
and we get all kinds of cool skill development.
And then every day
I walk for between 45 minutes and two hours.
And those are long walks with Ananda, my German Shepherd.
And the, because you went there
and because I know
a large portion of your audience are athletes,
a big part of the strength training,
somewhat related to the principles in this book,
is it gives me something that is tangible and measurable
where there's concrete improvement,
that doesn't depend on what other people think.
So if I put a book out into the world,
I have no control whether or not people buy it.
I try as hard as I can to practice what I preach
and say, "Well, what are my core values?
What's my internal dashboard? Did the book live up to them?
What do the people I respect most think of the book?"
But still it's out there in the world.
Sales numbers are a thing; they matter.
Whereas in the weight room I get this thing
that I can work to make progress at
that is solely in my control.
The closest thing to it is like a pool,
cause like even in running and cycling,
there's weather conditions change, but like
45 pounds is 45 pounds, you know,
a hundred meters is a hundred meters.
So I think it's important for me,
it helps me stay grounded, to have this very real thing
that the successes are a hundred percent concrete
and can be traced directly to myself
and the failures are in my face.
I can't be like,
"Well, it was a bad news cycle," or, "People don't get it."
It's like, "No, like I, I didn't hit the weight."
But it's something that I struggle with all the time.
It's something I talk about with my therapist all the time
is, "Am I just addicted to progress?"
Like, why do I still care how much I squat?
Why do I need a goal to chase?
Why can't I just be okay
walking my dog for an hour and a half?"
That's a good question.
It, I spend a lot of time
tumbling that around in my mind.
I mean I think
having a healthy relationship with those numbers
is important,
but irrespective of that,
to be in the habit or the practice of challenging yourself
to do hard things,
Yes.
Is important to developing resilience across the board,
emotional and physical resilience
and just the sheer humility that it gives you.
Yeah. Like, especially when you get older and it's like,
you can't do the stuff you used to be able to do.
I think all of that is super healthy.
And then of course the integrated, you know,
mind-body system requires it.
Like, "Emotionally I'm better.
I'm more present. I feel better.
I'm happier.
I just feel more grounded,"
Yes.
when I'm working out, right?
And, and that's, but that's movement,
that's not necessarily connected to a goal,
But, but that movement can be in the weight room, right?
Yes.
Oh for sure. It is.
But what I'm saying is it's like the goal,
like I always talk about with this guy at the gym, Zach,
I'm like,
"You know, at some point I'm just gonna come in here
to be healthy three days a week."
I'm not there yet. Like right now I still have a goal.
Right. And that goal is what just like pushing these PRs?
Yeah. I mean this, this arbitrary numbers,
but I'd love to, it's like 5, 4, 3 in power lifting world.
So it's dead lift 500 pounds, squat 400 pounds
and bench press 300 pounds.
But goals add structure
and build accountability and drive.
Like in a, in a world in which
your attention, and time, and energy is limited,
when you have a goal,
it helps you prioritize how you focus that attention,
time, and energy.
Yes.
So there's nothing wrong with that
unless your attachment to that goal
or the outcome is unhealthy.
Yeah. And this is something that I wrote about recently.
So we'll dive in here really quick,
cause I think it's fascinating
and maybe you can give me some advice?
and I don't know if you saw it was just in the newsletter
so it wasn't like, you know, widely shared on,
on Outside magazine or anything like that.
But I recently had a fitness test
and for the first time in my life,
there was no part of my identity or self-worth
that was attached to the result.
And I couldn't find any extra gear.
So my relationship with athletics,
I was bullied when I was in first to third grade,
really badly, had to switch schools level bullying.
Then in seventh grade,
my parents wouldn't let me play football.
They were concerned about health.
And I got jumped on the side of the road by high schoolers,
like beat the crap outta me,
became super anxious to be outside of my own neighborhood
because I didn't feel safe.
Like they, they beat me to the ground.
Then my parents were like, "All right,
I guess we'll let Brad play football, for his confidence."
So I played football and I go in the weight room
and suddenly my ability to feel safe and confident
is totally related to my strength.
And then in high school, girls start liking me
not because of my brains,
it's because like the size of my arms
and I'm the captain of the football team
and my entire identity is connected to football.
So when I go to school at Michigan
and I'm not good enough to play there,
Right.
And I can't have anything to do with sports
with, excuse me, with the sport of football,
I don't even go to games anymore. It was too painful.
So I'm just kind of like, and I can't,
I don't lift for cosmetics.
That was never me.
Like it's meaningless. It has to have a goal.
My identity was so connected
to strength geared towards football.
So I kind of get into endurance sports
and I'm doing it as like a hobby level.
And then the girl that I dated throughout college,
dumps me kind of out of the blue.
And at the time that was really painful. So what do I do?
I totally numb it with triathlon.
I just train away all my pain,
all my insecurity around that.
Yeah. It's good for that.
And now triathlon is my identity
and I care deeply about triathlon.
Your higher power.
All of that stuff.
And for the first time in my life,
getting back into strength training,
which the long story made short
is to get better at triathlon
would've required training so much.
And my son was coming along.
I just like had gotten through the OCD thing.
It's like, you know,
"I'm just gonna go back to my roots
and start strength training again."
I joke with David Epstein, who wrote "Range," all the time.
Like my fit is definitely with strength training.
It took me 10 years to try to run a marathon.
It's equivalent to what I can squat after like two months.
So my body just responds to this kind of training better.
So I get back into strength training,
but for the first time in my life,
like I love my wife to death.
We live in a place where we're happy.
I've got this dog that I love.
My son means everything to me.
My professional identity
is connected to that book right there.
Maybe the that's not so healthy,
but certainly more than athletics.
And I can't find that extra gear.
I'm like, I just don't care if I make the lift.
So that's what I'm exploring now,
is like, "How do I find that extra gear?"
Or, "Do I even need to find that extra gear anymore?"
Cause it used to be, if I missed that squat,
my entire identity is on the line.
So of course you figure out a way to make it.
And now I'm just like,
"Well I already promised myself a breakfast burrito
regardless if I make this or not.
So like, it doesn't really matter."
Well age will purge that out of you.
Yeah. In what way?
Yeah.
You'll get to a point where that's just not part
of the conversation-
whether or not
you're gonna make the thing.
Right.
And so one of the things that my wife always says to me
that's super helpful is
cause you know, when I was training for Ultraman and all,
it's very performance metrics oriented.
Yes.
And you're carving out a huge amount of time
and you gotta make every minute count.
And I super focused on how this was gonna translate
into a certain result that I cared deeply about.
It's not about that anymore for me.
But then if it's not about that, what is it about?
And how are you finding meaning in it?
And Julie will say, "You gotta do it for the joy."
Like that's the, the sustainable energy source, right?
If you're, if you're, if you're chasing something else,
then, you know,
it's not gonna be something
you're gonna be able to stick with over time.
Yes.
And to tie it back to what we talked about for me
with strength training,
because it happens inside, it's purely related to community.
So my sustainability and strength training as I age,
will be directly related to my,
doing it with a group of other people
that I have fun with and I enjoy their company.
Cause if I were to do it alone,
like again, it doesn't really matter.
Right.
Why is meditation not one of these core principles?
It's a good question.
I think that I would,
I would argue that meditation is baked into all of them.
I, actually let me reframe.
I would argue that mindfulness is baked into all of them,
especially the presence principle,
but the act of meditation itself is not worthy
of a principle in a book on groundedness.
It's a practice that would be
within the subheading of presence.
Correct.
And meditation,
and I have a practice
and it's been a wonderful thing,
especially when I was going through OCD,
nothing is better exposure therapy
than sitting with your eyes closed
and being bombarded by
these intrusive thoughts and feelings
and then not being able to do anything.
Yeah.
So I'm a huge believer in meditation.
And meditation, today, has been completely ripped out
of the ancient wisdom traditions where it originated
and sold is like a balm for all that ails us.
When in fact,
you look at any of the contemplative traditions,
that meditation was a part of
and the actual act of sitting with your eyes closed
and having an anchor,
tends to be one of five to eight other principles.
And in Buddhism, which is the tradition here in the West,
that is most closely associated with meditation,
it's actually just one of eight parts
of what the Buddha called the noble eightfold path.
And meditation was taught in Buddhism after ethics.
So right action came before right being.
And I think that meditation itself,
like your practice, is only as strong as your life.
So if you think that
sitting with your eyes closed for 20 minutes a day
is going to somehow help you find freedom,
or fulfillment, or enlightenment,
but then you get off the cushion,
and your life is like
Completely ungrounded,
completely ungrounded,
it's not gonna work.
So I see it as a practice
that supports all of these principles.
Also in Buddhism, Sangha,
which is the word for community,
was taught before meditation.
My favorite parable, cause
I'm on a little Buddhist kick in the whole book.
I mentioned that my German Shepherd's named Ananda,
and here's why.
So in the Pāli Canon,
which is one of the oldest living texts
that we have of Buddhism,
Ananda was the Buddha's loyal attendant.
And throughout these scriptures and text
he's painted as like this
overly eager, enthusiastic, curious,
wanting to soak up all the knowledge from the Buddha,
person.
And Ananda goes up to the Buddha one day
and there's tons of repetition in the Pāli Canon,
but I think it's it serves its purpose.
So he says, "Buddha, Buddha Blessed One, Blessed One.
I've just heard that good comradeship,
good friendship, and good Sangha
is 50% of the spiritual path.
Could this possibly be true?"
And Buddha says, "No Ananda, no, you are mistaken.
No, good comradeship, good Sangha, good friendship,
is not 50% of the spiritual path."
And Ananda looks at the Buddha and says,
"What is it, Blessed One, what could be true?"
And the Buddha looks at him and he says,
"Ananda, good comradeship, good friendship,
good Sangha is the whole of the spiritual path."
There was nothing in there about meditation.
So I think that it's a very powerful tool,
but it's gotta be-
But meditation,
meditation being a tool that would be important for Sangha
and important for
all these things-
Oh, it's important
for everything.
And, and again,
when I'm at my best, I sit for 20 minutes a day,
doesn't happen as much with a young kid,
but it is a extremely powerful tool,
but I think it needs be situated in a broader framework.
And what's great about meditation too,
is we talked in acceptance about self-distancing,
giving advice to a friend.
Meditation's a great way to do that.
Sure. Cause you start to see thoughts,
feeling, situations in your life,
from the place of being an observer, not in them.
And then it's the observing you,
the more you connect with that, you're essence, your core,
your spirit, whatever you wanna call it,
the more that you can start
to make decisions out of that place.
Right.
And the greater capacity you have
to respond from a place of neutrality
to all of the stressors in your life.
Neutrality or perhaps even compassion?
That's what I get outta meditation.
Meditators understand this. I didn't when I first heard it.
And now I think it's
one of the most beautiful quotes on meditation.
It's an anonymous source,
but this woman at the end of her life
was reflecting on her meditation practice.
And she said that, "Every itch not scratched
was a lesson in compassion."
I'm just chewing on that. Explain that.
Well, how I interpret that
is that when you're sitting,
whether it's a physical itch or a mental itch,
something comes up and you wanna deal with it.
And the practice is just to-
Your have to let it,
plan it.
Let it
Right, exactly.
And learning-
Learning the allowing.
And learning to let it be there
helps you become a more compassionate person to yourself,
to others, because we all
have all these itches that we wanna scratch all the time.
And it's so hard to live a life
where we're bombarded with these things that we wanna fix:
with loss, with disappointment,
with all these things, and learning to accept it,
if that doesn't make you a more compassionate person,
then like what will?
Right.
Let's let's close this thing down
with some practical takeaways for people.
So perhaps somebody's been listening to this,
they're thinking, "Okay, I'm on board, Brad,
I'm gonna get the book,
but help me with a few simple things
that I can begin to incorporate into my life
to cultivate groundedness."
So we've talked about these things
from kind of a 10,000 foot view,
but, and in the book you have like practices,
like here's the, here's how you kind of do things.
So you it's certainly in the book,
but what are a few of your favorites
or things that you think could be helpful to somebody
who's trying to, you know, blaze this path?
Yeah. Blaze it slowly.
Right? The patience thing.
Yeah. No, but blaze it is good.
It's slow variety.
It's good to have,
It's good to have motivation
As Eliud Kipchoge,
the greatest runner and
potentially the greatest athlete of all time,
talked about his progress,
and he's literally like the fastest human on earth
over long distances,
says he makes progress slowly by slowly.
Right.
And you talk about you,
you write about him rarely
going beyond 80%-
In his workouts,
in, in his workouts.
And, and this notion of like, you know,
one less rep, or like not going to max out.
Yeah.
as being a kind of habit
of building sustainability into your daily routine.
So, so yes, I love that.
And just like the compounding consistency.
And you've had other guests that talk about that topic
and have whole books on that topic.
So a couple of like really tactical things.
The first is the core values work I think is,
can be really transformative.
So it doesn't have to be more than a half an hour, an hour,
but try to come up with the three to five qualities
that you really aspire towards, that are you,
when you're at your best,
and then define them in concrete terms.
And then for each of those qualities,
talk about things that you will do or that you'll stop doing
that allow you to practice them.
Something else.
The three you tell, yeah.
The three things that you wanna adopt
and the three things you wanna let go of.
Yes, in service of that core value.
So if your core value is vulnerability,
well, what are you doing that goes away from that?
And what could you do that works toward that?
If your core value is love, how do you, again,
how do you define it? What do you do?
How do you get from love to,
"I'm gonna put my phone in the glove compartment of the car
and leave it in the garage."
Start trying to thank nondualy.
So when you catch yourself being like,
"I need to be self-disciplined,"
how can you be self-disciplined and self-compassionate?
How can-
That's yes/and.
How can you sometimes go fast
and realize when it's important and to step back
and be good enough and go a little bit slow, more slowly.
And then another thing that I think is just, is,
is really helpful and, and has an immediate effect,
is try to catch yourself shoulding on yourself
and try to replace that self-talk with wish or want.
And that's the whole intervention
and just watch what happens.
My coaching clients like,
"Wait, you mean that that's gonna change things?"
Like just try it.
And some of the most perfectionist people
that are hardest on themselves after a few months,
they're like, "Wow, like, you're right.
Like when I catch myself shoulding, all I do is be like,
'I wish I could do that. I want to do that.'"
And it just lessens that second arrow.
That's the big one for me,
cause obviously that's my Achilles heel right now.
When I read the book
and just in the conversations that we've had,
I feel like you read my mind and you know,
everything that I've been able to kind of achieve
is a result of practicing the things that you talk about.
I mean, I remember the first podcast we did.
I met you in a hotel lobby and it was
you, me and Steve, in a tiny hotel room.
The second time you came to my house
and we had a set up and we filmed it, and now you're here.
Well that took place over a number of years,
that progressive of growth.
And that growth is the result of,
you know, making incremental progress on the daily,
not having any kind of viral, crazy spikes,
but just showing up for the thing, day in, day out,
trying to get a little bit better, iterating,
and being patient, you know,
these things take time
and I've been doing this for 10 years at this point.
And I feel like I've grown into or matured into a place
where I can kind of own this space
in a way that I couldn't have
the first time that we did a podcast.
And that's just the way it works.
So for people who are struggling, or feel stuck,
or feel like they're falling behind their peers,
try to have a broader view on your trajectory and,
and exercise a little bit of that self-compassion,
and tend to yourself, and try to figure out
the one thing that you can do that day that's tiny,
that no one would care about, perform it anonymously.
Do it again the next day.
And it's only over an extreme amount of time
that you begin to see results
or that those results are reflected back to you
by other people who can see what you can't.
I mean, I remember being in AA for years
thinking I wasn't getting better
and feeling like my life had stalled out
and I had no trajectory,
But I just kept going to meetings. I kept showing up.
I kept just trying to get a commitment or do the thing.
And I really felt static in my life.
And I felt all my peers were passing me by
because I couldn't see the growth
or the foundation of growth that I was creating
that would allow me to do things later in life.
And I think the patience piece is like really powerful.
And I think that's an opportunity for people
to be gentle on themselves and exercise a little bit of,
you know, direct that grace inward.
I love it. I couldn't have closed it any better.
It's a practice.
Yeah.
You know, the book's not called get grounded
for a reason,
Get Grounded Today.
Like this is an ongoing practice
and life is a practice
and you gotta show up and some days are better than others.
And you just get on the path and you fall off the path
and you get back on and you repeat that interval.
And, and if things go well, you learn and grow
and hopefully have some fun along the way.
Right on, brother.
Well, the book is amazing. It's a gift to humanity.
I know you're already hard at work on the next thing.
So you'll have an opportunity to come back
and share about that as well.
But I wish you well.
Everybody should check out this book,
"The Practice of Groundedness,"
and all of Brad's other books,
"The Passion Paradox, and "Peak Performance," right?
Available, wherever you buy books.
You can also check out Brad's email newsletter and podcast,
"The Growth Equation." What is it?
The growtheq.com. Is that the website you.
You are right on.
Yeah.
There you go.
And Brad is pretty active on Twitter.
He likes to throw down these massive threads.
I do what I can-
If you're into that,
check 'em out there.
Steve Stolberg there, right?
Yep. That's that's the scoop.
And I just wanna thank you for this.
I'm just, it really this, for whatever reason this time,
you know, it's always a pleasure to be with you,
but I was just feeling so grateful.
I think some of it is we tried to do it earlier,
but my kid wasn't vaccinated, pandemic stuff.
So just to, to be here and to be able to sit down with you
is a joy.
So thank you.
The feeling is mutual, my friend.
Mad respect, much love,
and you're always welcome here.
Thank you.
(atmospheric music playing)